how's it going ladies and gentlemen
welcome to tim cast irl podcast if
you're not a subscriber please smash
that subscribe button and that like
button and that notification bell so uh
you can make sure you stay tuned to the
shows we got a bunch of interesting
stories and topics to talk about today
the big story that's just breaking now
is that amid the ongoing derek chauvin
trial
minneapolis has agreed to settle with
the family of george floyd for a
historic 27 million dollars in a
wrongful death suit there's a lot of
questions around why they would do this
and how this is going to impact the
trial of this officer and whether or not
he's going to be able to get a fair
trial now the city is basically
admitting fault
i think ultimately it results in riots a
couple other stories though scotland
my friends over in scotland count
dankula man they got it bad a new
anti-free speech laws coming into effect
there's some news about cuomo there's
they're apparently trying to cancel
eminem because you know eminem is uh
edgy and i guess racist and homophobic
and transphobic and bigoted and all
those really awful things and these
young people are now realizing the kind
of music this guy was making so he made
a a rebuttal song i don't think the song
is that good but we'll certainly talk
about it and to assist us in navigating
the world of woke we have one of the
preeminent scholars engaging in
criticizing critical race theory
wokeness we have james lindsay hey tim
yeah
you want to introduce yourself explain
uh you know what you do a little bit i i
wrote about woke so i mean you did a
great job you call me a preeminent
scholar yeah i'm gonna do better than
that i like to tell people that i'm one
of the best i'm only one of the leading
scholars on critical race theory et
cetera critical theory among people who
don't believe it
and so there are probably people who are
advocates and adherents who are in the
faith who
know it more deeply and more
more thoroughly than i do maybe not
but i don't believe it i think it's
wrong i think it's actually racism
reinvented and going to as much steps as
you want it's just racism
and uh that's what i do i have a website
new discourses
it's newdiscourses.com and i tried to
put up podcasts videos and written
material and writing an encyclopedia
explaining how the woke talk how they
they misuse words
and uh that's about it it's all i do
these days and you're uh fairly
pessimistic i guess huh i'm a little
pessimistic right now yeah yeah i'm not
i mean i vary it's like so black pill is
a thing right so people don't know what
a black pill is you got like all these
pills because the freaking matrix came
out and now everything's a pill
yeah right orange pills the bitcoin one
is that that's max kaiser's podcast yeah
i didn't even know about that pill
there's too many kills
i know about the blue pill the blue pill
means you want to stay in the matrix i
know about the red pill and that means
you think that the media is lying and
you want out of the matrix and then
there's there's there's a clear pill
that's like i don't care about any of
this
like it's when george carlin back in the
day you remember george carlin had that
thing where he was like i don't care who
wins i think it's all crap yeah you know
i have no stake in the outcome any
longer i'm just going to write jokes and
he's like near the end of his life and
he's just kind of old man ranting
that's going clear pill like you don't
you have no stake in the outcome anymore
just watching and you just go clear for
yourself then there's black pill which
means uh
it's over it's over it's over depressed
that's it despair and then there's white
pill where all of a sudden you see hope
and i guess there's orange pill that's
racist bro oh i didn't white pills
racism i mean a lot of pills are white
but some of them are pink and some of
them are blue yeah this is like it's
it's the weird world where colors all of
a sudden represent race in any context
so like uh true you know ian and i and a
couple other people in the house we all
play magic the gathering it's a card
game it's
and they have colors it's like each card
can have a different color and so
because half your swamp
right right was like a teenager all
right so yeah because they use the
colors white and black there are certain
cards they've deemed racist for simply
using the mechanic of black magic like
this fantasy idea that's that's that's
the depravity of of wokeness well that's
in their literature that's actually in
their scholarly literature like that's
in the books they're literally literally
in their scholarly books that they write
that that the association with black
magic being bad and white magic being
good
is is like proof that you but you know
what the you know what really comes from
uh
night and day oh sure yeah that was
literally what it was it was light and
dark it was at night things were dying
it was dangerous there were predators in
the winter it got darker and everything
died and it was scary and people got
scared and then when the sun was out we
were warm and we were safe
and so we just created this idea of
light and dark good and bad had nothing
to do with the color of someone's skin
yeah now they've made it that way yeah
yin and young and chinese are as as
those gringos would say yin and yang
yin is the black one everybody and
yang is the is the white one and it is
the creative and the in the receptive if
you're going to kind of taoist cosmology
super racist though because asians are
like more racist now i guess asians are
more white than white people i guess
yeah they they were white adjacent for a
while and they're also a model minority
and now though they are just white but
then they're super white because they
get to claim that they're also a
minority so they get to hide from being
white so they're like actually
sneaky it's like it's like super
straight but super white
but instead of being like good it's bad
it's it's all upside down it's it's all
clown world we'll we'll get into this
stuff too we got ian's channel oh hey
everybody ian crossland ian
crossland.net and i just want to point
out that black and white are not colors
they are shades oh yeah that is
correct
they are shades and tints or something
like that yeah yeah and then there's me
in the corner pushing buttons correctly
this time and i have no say in this
color argument so i'll turn it back to
tim before we get started go to
timcast.com and sign up to become a
member to get exclusive access to
members only podcast episodes and
segments and uh i don't know if y'all
are into this stuff but the other day
with kim iverson she was talking about
destiny cards and apparently i'm the ace
of spades and i'm as far as i'm
concerned that's like the best card of
course and so naturally i was like tell
me more madam and we did like a
40-something minute segment where she
broke down what destiny cards are it's a
kind of astrology and i'm not i'm not a
big you know believer in any of this
stuff but she talked about how she
predicted donald trump would be defeated
but not feel defeated and didn't
understand what it meant until it
happened was like now i get it so it's
interesting stuff but of course we also
have scott pressler who was talking
about primarying these america last
politicians so that's more your cup of
tea become a member and don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe the
notification bell let's check out this
first story and then we'll just we'll
just get into this stuff because
this is from cbs news minneapolis
approves historic 27 million dollar
settlement with george floyd's family
they say
the city council voted 13-0
to approve the settlement which directs
half a million dollars to be used to
benefit the george floyd memorial site
at 38th and chicago
do you know what that means
uh i'm gonna build a suspense on y'all
for a minute 13-0 this past weekend yeah
the george floyd memorial site which is
an autonomous zone someone was shot and
killed
the city has just announced they are
going to fund this antifa autonomous
zone to the tune of half a million
dollars
that's the degree to which this insanity
i'm sorry james you may say that you're
a little pessimistic but boy am i
getting pessimistic on this one 27
million dollars in a civil settlement to
the family look i'm i'm upset the guy
died i don't like it when anybody dies
27 million historic why
because the terror worked
that's right the burning down the cities
it worked that's right so what are you
going to see
more fire yep yeah they're giving half a
million dollars to these people yeah now
the crazy thing too is
chauvin is still on trial
and so you have these jurors who are
supposed to be coming in and being asked
if they can remain in partial and now
they're going to be told you know in the
civil case
they've already won clearly he must be
guilty of something the city's agreed to
settle how can this guy get a fair trial
o.j simpson lost a civil case once after
that wasn't it i think the civil case
was after the criminal case though in
his case it's funny
um i don't know the history of civil
case criminal case the the ad the
adjunctives of it like do you
is there a precedent for doing a civil
case first finding them i'm not a lawyer
i have no idea i do know that you know
this was a wrongful death and that he's
being tried for murder one right no
murder two three and manslaughter okay
so yeah who knows then
um because the city is sort of admitting
admitting fault here yep and uh
i can't see that i don't see how you
yeah i mean i mean i guess theoretically
maybe the judge will be like no no no
you've got to separate that and maybe
when it comes to the the defense they'll
say a settlement is not an
admission of guilt the city just simply
thought paying out would be less
expensive than the damage and he might
actually say
the fact the city thought 27 million
dollars was cheaper than fighting the
suit shows what they really feared was
the riots from the extremists who are
trying to destroy the city well yeah of
course i mean that's what the whole gig
is an extortion gig all right i get that
there's like oh there's the passion
people are locked down i don't want to
like deny the ab you know that what was
the saying we had to endure it was a
quote from from martin luther king but i
felt like it was
taking a bit out of context
which was uh that a riot is the the
voice of the unheard or something like
that and i get it people are locked down
for months people are like kind of out
of their their minds looking for
something to do there's this flash point
everything goes crazy
but um
it's an extortion gig the the whole
because because the theory underlying it
if we look at critical race theory is an
extortion gig it works on public
relations they're not riots but it also
defends things like looting there's that
book defense defensive looting that's
all rooted in critical race theory and i
was crazy stuff that was written about
ferguson i was in ferguson and when that
article came out i threw up in my mouth
a little bit
it was it was like reading that was
a combination of several different
uh what's the right word for this
like like
violations of ethics
the first was
to see the people desperately defending
their their town
their their their neighborhood from
these violent rioters and looters were
exploiting them to see the manipulation
and fake news and the corruption of the
media it was like all at once and i was
like oh
in ferguson
the kids who lived there
some young men linked arms around the
convenience store
and they were trying to defend the
businesses from the looters who came
from out of town to exploit and steal
and burn things down because they
thought it was funny they didn't care
and then along comes these ultra woke
white progresses from the suburbs who
have no idea what it's like to live in
poverty cheering on the criminals who
invaded this neighborhood and attacked
the poor marginalized people who lived
there and i witnessed it that's in
ferguson right thousand ferguson okay
yeah so what happened in in minneapolis
is you know the person who's now the
vice president coming out and saying
this needs to continue let's bail them
all out of jail here's a link to the
fund kamala harris kamala harris yeah
yeah and people thought that if she got
elected the i i this is true that she
was the the tough cop the top cop she
was going to come and put an end to this
antifa stuff this this violence
and uh i remember talking to uh some
people i know in the chicago suburbs
they were talking about why they were
supporting biden and i was like don't
you think that under biden these these
extremists are emboldened and the rights
are going to get worse
and there are people who said dude
kamala is like
was like locking up innocent people
pretty sure she's going to go nuts
and i was like dude she tried bailing
these people out she she solicited funds
to get them out of jail what's happening
now
they said the they set the mark uh oh
hatfield court uh courthouse on fire
again in portland that's right yeah and
speaking of portland you know i remember
talking to some folks that i'm friends
with in portland and um their big
concern going into the election these
are people lifelong democrats or
progressives or leftists or whatever as
portland would do
and
their concern was well our city isn't
protecting us our state isn't protecting
us you'll get the ted wheeler the mayor
you look at was it kim brown is that her
name the governor of oregon maybe i've
got kim wrong but i think that's right
and then
the last line of defense it's like trump
and you know he can't his hands are
tight he can't even send in like federal
troops or the national guard or anything
and then
their concern was you know if
biden and harris win
now every level of government whether
city state or federal
is going to do nothing to protect the
city of portland and now like you said
that was the federal courthouse was on
fire with people inside right it was set
on fire with people inside law
enforcement and they had to rush out and
try to put the fire out yeah do you
think they should have sent the feds in
the trump should have sent the feds in
i mean it's complicated right there is
the the way that antifa works and a lot
of people don't understand this and if
you say oh it's black lives matter when
it's not antifa sometimes it is there's
there's this wing of black lives matter
that i think is called black lives
matter revolution but we could look that
up
that's the activist wing the
paramilitary ring the way that they work
is what's called inducing mid-level
violence a lot of people don't
understand that there are levels of
violence or how violence works and what
mid-level violence is is that kid
the brothers right in the back of the
car i'm not touching you i'm not
touching you i'm not touching you and
what they want is you to either back
down and show weakness or to overreact
and so we were referring to this over
the summer as the trump trap
is that if he sent in federal troops aha
he's a fascist he's sending in federal
troops on american citizens that was the
narrative was there this whole game is
driving narratives we see this with
what's happening in minneapolis now you
see it there
the entire operative or operation of
what's happening is a narrative driven
maneuver where you have a collusion
between big media the democratic party
to seize power and the narrative is the
thing so the game was to put trump in a
lose-lose situation oh he's too weak he
didn't do anything to protect anybody he
didn't do anything but if he had done it
the narrative would have slipped the
other way oh he's a fascist see we've
been telling you for four years we've
been conditioning you for four years
trump's a fascist he's going to seize
power he's going to take over everything
and now he's sending federal troops
against american citizens that's exactly
what would have happened so his hands
were tied um
from what i understand he was also told
you know by
by military brass if you make this order
we won't follow it and so what's he
going to do you know then he gets put in
the same trap now with these other
people he has to force him or
or back down and look weak and the same
narratives are going to be able to get
spun out of this and this is what people
don't understand and i mean i don't want
to make this like left right or whatever
but the radical left
understands narrative and political
warfare and nobody else does and so
that's how they keep catching everybody
with their pants down political warfare
is the most important concept you've
never heard of
uh
and political warfare are foreign
adversaries reported a few decades ago
i think china and russia both had had
remarked that the american ability
because we rely so much on physical
warfare we have such high technology we
have bad ass jets you know the whole
thing
we don't even think about political
warfare anymore they said it's so
degraded that it might as well not exist
and this is what we're losing right now
is political warfare and the radical
left is
trained they're excellent at it they
think about it constantly and they put
people in these traps these mid-level
violence traps we're particularly
susceptible to it because this country
is classically liberal and that and i
know a lot of people need to understand
what that means classically liberal that
doesn't mean conservative or liberal in
the colloquial sense it means
believing in freedom and government for
of by the people things like that so
this country is a constitutional
republic with philosophically liberal
values liberal as a term seems to have
just gradually evolved to mean i guess
democrat so but it was like john locke
that invented right right classical
liberalism is much more similar to like
center-right libertarianism
if anything and then social liberalism
is the civil rights kind of era people
who believed in free speech and respect
for you know people and things like that
so that that came about but those of us
who occupy this like moderate
libertarian space kind of left kind of
right maybe depending on who you are
uh well we're playing fair and we
believe in respecting the rights and
speech of the of the of of our opponents
the problem then is i routinely stand up
and defend
leftists who get censored
they gloat and laugh when it's us
getting censored that's right or i will
absolutely and i did defend taylor
lorenz in this in the wake of this uh
you know criticism
of her because she this woman from the
new york times put out a tweet saying
that you know her life was literally
destroyed by harassment i saw a tweet
and i thought it was a silly thing to
say but i'm not going to be bothered by
yelling at someone on twitter simply
because i thought something they said
was silly otherwise my my whole day
would be nothing but that
well she started getting a lot of
criticism and i just ultimately said
look i get it if you want to criticize
the idea in the institution please do so
but you know getting into the weeds and
getting into the drama i think is is a
waste of our time
i absolutely tweeted in her defense
multiple times made videos in her
defense because i don't like the idea of
people piling on and engaging in this
culture war drama
and then not only uh i won't go into
details but now there's literally a
harassment campaign being fun being
promoted by large powerful institutions
putting insane and ridiculous lies out
about me
talking about where i live and and my
home
and and absolutely engaging in a
targeted harassment campaign and they're
all laughing about it they're all
laughing about it so i can stand on
principle and say like let's not do this
guys and then what happens then is the
people on you know the anti you know
woke side the people who believe in
freedom say it's warfare and we have no
choice they started it
that's the problem you know i believe in
a principle and if my principles are we
don't do these tactics then i am at an
extreme disadvantage where i can only
get i can sit back and turn the other
cheek when they do these things to me to
my family to my friends but if we dare
speak up you know glenn greenwald points
this out they will come for you and they
will use the weight of all of these
institutions to destroy you and even
when i still defend them they don't care
they are bad people no this is why i say
that i mean i've written an article i
think i did a podcast both of these
things that i actually called
wokeness but it could be radical leftism
in general or even any certain
totalitarian strain
that i called it radical left wokeness
in particular i called a virus on the
liberal body politic it takes advantage
of certain liberal cultural and ethical
mores
specifically to to do exactly as you
just described to absolutely neuter the
host
ability to defend itself your immune
system's not there you know
i like to actually kind of say frankly
i've kind of gotten hard about cancel
culture and my my belief there is that
the asymmetry is the story
it's no longer it's just it's not
culture war there's a power grab
happening i'm not quite as far as the
the
right or like it's war we have to act
like war but the asymmetry is a story
and so for me until we
adopt an attitude if someone wants to
cancel you cancel them first four or
five times because it won't take that
many they that there is a realization
that this is a
you know mutually assured destruction
that this that this horrific thing is
going to continue but what it requires
is a suspension of one's principles as a
classical liberal which puts us in that
decision dilemma yet again and also by
the way i don't know if it's called
is it gfas is that the george floyd
autonomous zone is that
yeah
but listen but no that's the same thing
though right just wanted to point out
well since we don't so we don't lose it
that's also mid-level violence right and
the city has decided to show weakness by
giving them whatever half a million
dollars
yeah so uh their other option of course
is to send them troops and just bulldoze
this they won't do it apparently it's
been there for like nine months they put
in half a million dollars now as part of
this settlement and someone just died
there recently and the police couldn't
get in to help this person
so
i'll i'll say this now my opinion very
much changing the autonomous zones i'm
here for it you know what roll with it i
left these cities you know i i it's
funny i'm in the philadelphia area
previously and i was like there's too
many riots and they cross the bridge and
they're coming into these neighborhoods
so i think it's time to start
considering not being in these cities
because it's not about antifa it's not
about black lives matter it's just about
opportunistic violence when things start
you know going crazy and we had a year
of riots well sure enough i think it was
like a week after we we didn't move out
officially we we
started the process and came down to the
new location riots broke out mass
shootings there was like a hostage
situation and i'm like
there you go man i mean homicides are on
the rise everywhere and so i think
people need to realize
i think the last group of people i'm
worried about in a big city is people
like antifa i mean a lot of these people
are like suburban privileged scrawny you
know angsty youths i really don't care
my bigger concern in philadelphia there
was a bunch of armed dudes like repeat
offender criminals occupying buildings
and shooting at cops and you've got
that kind of crime you've got the
homicide skyrocketing you've got the gun
crime skyrocketing you've got just theft
across the board even petty theft and
these crimes in a lot of these cities
partly due to the demoralization of the
police the defense hold on hold on
nobody knows why it's happening
so that's what i learned the media yeah
nobody knows last summer it was because
it was summer and in the winter maybe it
was because it was winter but i don't
know
but nobody knows yeah they're like you
see in the summer
uh it's it's it's warm giving more
people the opportunity to go out and
more people outside means
more crime will happen right
more
right and in the winter it's darker
which means a more opportunity to commit
crime and then in the springtime as the
weather starts getting nicer people want
to go back outside again so then crime
just in it just exponentially increases
non-stop this has nothing to do with
defunding the police nothing to do with
uh you know a demoralization of police
just
happenstance just nothing to do i'm just
telling them to stand down nothing to do
with da's letting people off if they get
arrested nothing to do nothing to do
nothing nothing to do with the city of
minneapolis putting half a million
dollars into an anti-fun autonomous zone
hey we're at that point now where it's
like the autonomous zone has official
government sanction you know in this
place
and
it's it's it's remarkable so
where where where are the conservative
or right-wing autonomous zones because i
i i mean this is right here in this
house
yeah really no i'm talking about no no
no not at all what i'm specifically
talking about was uh uh when are we
gonna start seeing
right-wing dudes standing in the road
the hype the the u.s state highway or
whatever that leads into a small town of
a few thousand people city blocks just
doing checkpoints they did this in the
pacific northwest when the wild fight
when the fires kept starting and this is
one of the things you know joe rogan i'm
uh you know one of the things i'm
disappointed with him about is that he
had said on his show he was wrong he
made a mistake that you know antifa was
going on starting these fires
he then made an apology which said none
of it was true it's not happening
the issue was that it there was a guy
who was like a leftist who was caught
starting the fires and there were other
people many who were not politically
affiliated who were just crazy firebug
types so you need to explain to people
when these photos came out showing
right-wing dudes with signs saying you
know checkpoint and then they were
explaining people are starting fires the
media made it seem like conspiracy
crackpots were tracking were scared of
antifa sure some of them were there was
one story about a leftist who got
arrested but a lot of irregular people
like i don't care who they are or what
their affiliation is they started fires
and there was a handful of people across
the posit the west coast that did
so you know joe's apology kind of just
got it wrong but it's you know it's fine
i don't think he was intentional but
there's there are a lot of people on the
left that absolutely engage in ongoing
and sustained violence and over the past
year it's only worked so so my point is
and they're opportunistic to that stuff
right yeah when are we going to see in
response to these autonomous zones
right-wing groups just setting up in
their communities there there was a
viral video where you know anti-foot
group went into a neighborhood in
colorado and a bunch of regular guys
just
chased them out
and uh did not go well for those guys
because actual working class like union
boys
they're not scrawny suburbanite
privileged white kids no they're men who
went out and were basically like welcome
to my neighborhood and the intimate
people ran off so i'm wondering if the
city is going to give half a million
dollars to benefit the george floyd
memorial site at 30th in chicago which
has become an autonomous zone locked
down where black-clad individuals
threaten journalists and refuse to let
police and the police haven't been in
months apparently
when do we see conservatives have a
peaceful autonomous zone where they set
up checkpoints i mean you know the
answer to that question never and the
answer is because the left owns the
political warfare like i just said it's
the most important concept you've never
heard of and uh
why what's going to happen well you know
what the media is going to do with
immediately it could be as peaceful as
peaceful it could be literally doing
nothing but growing flowers
feeding the feeding the hungry you know
bringing out whatever the most
pro-social thing you can possibly
imagine is and it's going to be a crazy
right-wing militia group of kkk blah
blah blah what they're going to say
about it and it's going to be white
supremacist white supremacist white
supremacist and because those words
those ideas it's not just that they have
power because that's one thing it's
actually that they stick like the word
conservative
as somebody who like has never
identified as one has been tainted
almost to the point of like absolute
i guess taint and it's just completely
poisoned and so conservatives seem to
understand this i put this on twitter
a while back
and i said that the meme is mightier
than the ar-15 and a bunch of gun guys
were like well i'll show you mine i'm
like shut up
it's like shut up it's not true the only
ar-15 rounds that were fired i don't
know how many actually fired but three
hit people from from kyle rittenhouse
he had two two three rounds yeah so the
only rounds that came out of it out of
an ar-15 were like those like all summer
there abouts you know approximately and
why because every law-abiding gun owning
citizen knew
that the second somebody opened fire
guns are gone you know or the bid to
take guns is gonna start and they knew
the meme the meme of gun toting right
wingers and look what happened to kyle
like that was brutal yeah the meme was
actually more powerful an ar-15 that you
can't fire because you know it's going
to get turned against you in the
narrative war and you're going to lose
that political war over it
uh that meme is more powerful than the
gun it's an ancient thought the pen is
mightier than the sword yeah that's what
i was i mean i was riffing
yeah i didn't quite think of that one
myself i'll tell you what the real
divide is right so you've always always
been like a fairly liberal person yeah i
have as well yeah and ian i think you
are pretty like i used to be super
liberal what i mean super liberal like
like free everyone no go we don't need
weapons everything can be fine like just
pie in the sky borders
when i was yeah let everyone in we can
help everyone like all the time
when i was when i was younger i was like
an arko punk skateboarder you know i
could play baby i'm an anarchist on the
guitar and i still can from against me
and i know a lot of the against me songs
i love that band and uh
you know these days
it's it's it's all changed quite a bit
but the one thing that i think defines
uh
the actual
war
the culture war is those who read beyond
the headlines and those who don't that's
it
there's really good examples of the
examples of this if you go online and
you can actually see it so i'm actually
i'm actually actually interested in
maybe hiring a researcher to start
tracking this as a data point to go to
the subreddits of prominent progressive
youtube personalities
and read the comments and then actually
write it you know mark them for like who
read beyond the headline and who didn't
and then go to conservative ones and do
it because what i've noticed recently is
that as i've been browsing the
subreddits of several prominent
progressive youtubers
they don't actually read the articles
they'll comment on the headlines and
while it's true for most people when i
go to conservative you know
sites not not so much and this is also
exemplified in left-wing memes about
conservatives so there was one that i
saw uh
on reddit where they were mocking the
conservative subreddit because the
conservative subreddit made a point
about not allowing billionaires the
ability to manipulate and control our
elections and big tech and things like
that and they were mocking conservatives
as if the conservatives were the ones
who did it to themselves and it's like
i don't understand if you actually read
what they're talking about they're
agreeing with you like you've convinced
them
or do you not agree with them anymore
the issue was
the caricature of the conservative from
the headline does not accurately
represent the real world and that's true
for libertarians be it left or right or
centrists or whatever and so what i
found is
why is it that the people who you know
follow you james or would watch this
show are
more likely to be informed is it because
of this show no i don't think so it's
because of the nature of the individuals
who would watch the show yeah i agree
the people who go and turn on cnn and
hear wolf blitzer say a bunch of white
you know white supremacists stormed the
capital they go wow and they walk away
and then you have the headline that
appears on twitter and it says far right
white supremacist storm you know you
know let's do a better example you'll
turn on cnn and they'll say the white
supremacist group the proud boys you
know their leader was arrested and
they'll go whoa
and you'll see the headline white
supremacist leader of proud boys
arrested and people will see the
headline go wow and then people who are
more inclined to watch shows like this
will say okay click it and see a picture
of a black man as the leader of the
proud boys and go wait what
something doesn't make sense here yeah
something and that's like the red pill
moment no that's exactly right you
actually start reading the news that's
that's red pill level one right there
yeah um that's where you see like the
news
the headline especially is lying to you
right and then you start finding the
buried leads and then you start finding
the inconsistencies in the stories you
start noticing
you know
that the reporting doesn't match reality
and then all of a sudden you're like
wait a minute and what it's all been
framed up to be is like now you're a
conservative
right because you've read
right and it but you you're not a
conservative you're actually somebody
who engages information like fully or at
least more than almost zero i'll tell
you what else is really interesting too
in this whole debacle there's another
level to this
those who are algorithmically fed
red pilled type information countering
the narrative and those who are actually
engaged with the content in general what
happens is there are a lot of people so
i was talking to some guy i know today
and he said
he's like listen man you used to be
really good at everything and now all
you do is just basically you're like
like a hardcore trump supporter that's
all you do is just always always always
protecting trump and i was like do you
watch my show and i was like because we
do defend him we do criticize him he's
like i only ever see from you defending
trump and i said have you considered
that facebook and youtube are only
giving you the videos i produce out of
the you know three and a half hours per
day that i produce they're only showing
you the trump article that you know that
the trump defense ones and you're
they're ignoring the times we've talked
about him when we we you know we're
critical of him on war and john bolton
and things like that it's like i think
we i think we said john bolton 5 000
times and criticized trump for hiring a
bunch of dumb people
certainly we defended him and i did vote
for him that's true
but there's a lot of people who were
trump supporters who only ever got from
youtube the videos that were like trump
isn't that bad and then the times when i
was like here's what i don't like about
trump and here's what i'm mad about it
doesn't go to them because they're less
likely to click it so youtube isn't
incentivized to share those videos then
you'll get people on the left who are
only fed that content because it's more
likely to be watched by trump supporters
and then they're like this is all he
produces but then the people who
actually engage with the content who
would watch every episode i see them
coming and i'm commenting online and
they're like we're talking about he like
criticizes them all the time especially
ian and he's like when luke and dave
smith are on the show it was like a two
hours of just nothing but ragging on
trump awesome but people don't get there
for that show because the algorithm
doesn't give it to him
trump has a lot to be react not to take
it too far away from what you're saying
but all these people have enough to be
critical about i think i mean sure you
and this was actually one of the points
that i raised is one of the main reasons
i voted for trump
was because the media is like
relentlessly like totally actually
unfairly critical of trump constantly
and they were at the time covering up
the hunter biden laptop story it's like
there's no evidence they're going to be
critical of biden they're actually
covering up a story that's critical of
biden right now and i was like if the
media i mean the media's function the
point of a free press is to be able to
criticize power in a free country yep
and if that's not happening by whatever
set of
you know for whatever set of reasons
then you have to become skeptical of the
side that benefits from that
and that was part of the reason that i
wanted to vote for trump it seems like a
symbiotic reason like the clicks like
you were saying you it's a click bait
thing so they're making money off of it
and it's also politically infusive for
this liberal economic order basically
well right plus the i think tim was
describing that there's an echo chamber
aspect to the algorithm the algorithm
gets better and better and better it's
driven by machine learning so it gets
better and better and better at
predicting what kinds of things you will
click on and therefore play the first
five seconds of an ad of that they make
some fraction of a penny off of unless
you accidentally click on the ad and
then they make some slightly more
fraction of a penny accidentally click
on it i mean has anybody ever actually
clicked on one of those things
i click on ads on instagram oh yeah
it's dangerous dude there's cool stuff
there was one where it was like a mini
lightsaber oh i can tell you that it was
a torch but it wasn't like a
like a like it was awesome all i can
tell you then is that your algorithms
get are getting to know you very well
dude they showed me this solar torch
thing it's called whatever and it's got
like a jet like super long and he like
melts through a tin can and i was like i
have to buy that that is sort of a
seriously man toy that yeah every man
does need like could you send me that ad
actually yeah
no there is one here but literally i was
just like i can get a torch faster so i
just went and bought a torch yeah i was
like cool and then we like we have fires
in the back sometimes so i was like i'll
just use a torch yeah no that's fun but
no the truth is though that the the
whole point is that the algorithm's
supposed to learn
what you'll click on because it drives
their ad revenues
there doesn't have to be a nefarious
plot you don't have to have you know
whoever the directors of youtube and
these shadowy rooms saying oh we're
going to turn this all left all left all
left it doesn't have to be that
these algorithms are going to feed
people echo chambers and that's how you
end up getting like conspiracy theories
like whether it's q and on or blue and
on or whatever an honor wailing on i
made up on twitter whale a nun oh that
was when twitter you know they made that
was a bird bird watcher thing you know
and they put that they put a fake tweet
i don't know if it still exists but they
made the like fake news is everywhere on
twitter and they put you know a sample
fake tweet and it said whales
whales are not real they're robots
paid for by the government to control
you and i was like this is wailing on
and so i'm like making memes like they
look like a cue and as there's a whale
though with the tail it's like
so so here's what happens there was a
study a few years ago where
they tracked various networks on twitter
and then created a visualization i saw
that they found that digital marketing
overlaps with the resistance the
establishment democratic position
that means
the
what is that hashtag
the resistance yeah right right right
yeah so what happens is uh pepsi and
coke and oreo and whatever big brands
nabisco
their ad campaigns live in the same
universe as
anti-trump democrats
so their advertisings are crap are
crafted around this core group of
individuals which means if they see a
video where someone's sitting there like
with their eyes half closed and they go
i like donald trump they go
get our ads off that video
and then google says okay okay okay and
then google goes we just lost a 50
million dollar contract what happened
the guy said he likes trump okay we'll
ban it ban it we're losing 50 million
dollars yeah there it is yep there it is
i can tell you something a little
scarier than that i happen to know some
people who work in you know
ai development and all of this and so
this guy called me a while back
and he's like kind of big into all this
he's like a phd in it or whatever and
he's like yeah i don't know if you know
that they're actually
you know you have machine learning or
whatever the algorithms and how they
work they actually the people
who are behind that this you know you
have to with the machine learning
algorithm it's like the the machine
makes a guess and then humans are
training it by saying yeah i was a good
guest or a bad guess right and many not
always but in a lot of cases and
they're literally using
intersectionality as the guide to decide
what the right and wrong answers are and
so it's like you know oh was this white
supremacy you know it's
intersectionality is how they're using
to decide that kind of stuff and that's
what's
that's what's getting baked into those
algorithms meanwhile they publish
articles with the iron law of spoke
projection saying white supremacy is in
all of the algorithms we have to put
more intersectionality into the
algorithms a few a few years ago i was
hanging out with you and helen pluck
rose and peter pagosian and i got an
argument with uh with peter no that's
not a surprise and it was because i was
saying that the media was creating this
the it was it was social media
algorithms and he was adamant that was
coming from the universities
i think both both are true both are true
but the point i made was this i wat i
literally watched this happen i
experienced this i started working for
uh i started working in digital media
spaces end of 2011. i officially started
working for vice in 2013. i went to
disney i watched how they implemented
these things why they wanted to do it
they explained it to me and explained to
them why they were wrong but what
happened was it's very very simple
it's a simple algorithmic equation
when facebook started rising in
prominence in attention and generating
ad revenue
they started to notice that police
brutality videos were skyrocketing in
viewership something about it was just
getting more shares and more attention
and there's like a viral song this is
what happens when you call the cops
there were websites dedicated to nothing
but police brutality videos in the in
the alexa top 500 absolutely crazy all
they would do is just aggregate police
brutality videos
now sidetrack i'm sure a lot of young
people who are swimming in that are now
activists saying defund the police
because
their whole brains were matched by it
but something else happened
if you made a post and said police
brutality the algorithm recognized
people love this stuff
send it to them more but then something
else happened there were also videos
about social justice racism sexism
the algorithm also said man people love
these videos send it to everyone
and then something magical happened
racism
skyrocketing police brutality
skyrocketing and then all sudden someone
made racist police brutality and then
where if a racism video would get x
views and a police brutality video would
get wide views
a racism a police brutality and racism
segment would get x y views well i
should say x plus y because i don't want
to assume it's exponential x y minus
twenty percent or some algorithm of
increase an increase and so this created
a space
when digital news outlets started
getting tons of venture capital funding
they started to realize this is how you
make money a good example uh is there's
an exposan mike.com are you from you're
familiar with mike.com yeah it still
exists right um when they started they
were libertarian they were ron paul
libertarian apparently so it's been
reported and it was because ron paul was
very popular online the the ron paul
loved revolution so they were like okay
let's write these articles then they
started to play that game this at least
it's been reported this i'm if you want
to avoid litigation so this is what i
read and i could be wrong but uh my
understanding is that
they started
putting out
articles on social justice and then
creating formulas where it was like uh
you know x has an x problem or x has a y
problem and then all of a sudden
combining these different things was
getting more and more views and traffic
because if you had a community of people
who who watched police brutality in a
community of people who watched social
justice you mixed those communities
together and you maximize your
viewership
this pushed intersectionality as the
perfect ideology
all of a sudden we start we there's one
article from vice i can't remember the
exact title but it was like trans women
of color being beaten by police proves
the the requirement proves why we need
black lives matter and it was just like
every possible keyword mashed into a
headline to get as much traffic as
possible to maximize revenue and so long
as advertisers don't mind being on these
psychotic i mean this is like
the
when you read these articles like there
was a joke meme where a guy is like
sitting in a room and he's uh trying to
write a name for a vice article he's
trying to come up with a vice article so
he pulls a an adult toy out of a box and
throws it at the wall and it just sticks
and then he's like transgender ketamine
dealers of colombia or something just
random
that's that's basically what was
happening and then the advertisers are
like i'm okay with this
and so as long as that system functioned
and advertisers didn't care it was fine
and then they found their boogeyman with
trump
we saw gamergate happen
this was i mean the the start of the
culture where it's a very interesting
thing and i'm not i can't get into
history mostly because it's very
complicated you know i think the
gamergate was the first battle
but
what i think happened was these video
game websites
what do you write about you have a job
your job is to write five articles per
day or three articles per day you've
already wrote every walkthrough for you
know the new zelda game what do you
write
no new game coming out until the holiday
season um
speedrunner did a speed run
all right uh oh
video games racist oh yeah and sexist
and anti-gay
kkk go away put it all in a headline and
we got a hit article and then every day
they had to do that and then all of a
sudden that's what gaming became say the
sexist thing too and you put like a
picture of like a bikini anime chick or
something like that and then like you
you're also just getting guys that are
like oh yeah
chicken bikini because even though it's
a cartoon click whoops you have like a
sexist article a racist article
uh an anti-gay article and then you'd
make the sexist racist anti-gay article
and then those writers would go to other
companies and write an anti-gay article
over there that would enable them to to
you know tell us a telephone so yeah it
happened fast too yeah so big time
that's true because people were so
hungry and they desperately want this
confirmation bias and they love
tribalism but what happened is you'd get
one article you know where this outlet
would write some nonsensical drama about
completely not just total bs video gamer
accused of you know oh they're uh
stealing
a hundred dollars from their ex
and then
people would click on it and they'd be
like i can't believe he really did that
and the story nowhere in it would
actually say it actually happened but
then another app would pick it up and be
like i can't believe so-and-so was
accused of doing this then the next
article would say multiple reports now
can you know citing that this happened
and then loops all the way back around
and they create a circular feedback loop
of sourceless garbage
and the whole the whole thing is just
algorithmically trying to generate
revenue here's the best part though
they've created this feedback loop where
they're basically parasites right you
know like i think the conversations we
have are imperfect we're not the best we
we engage in culture war stuff too and
nobody is perfect but i think we try to
have legitimate conversations
really break down these ideas to the
best of our abilities
what they do is they just leech and
parasite
so recently we had uh this this
journalist from axios got a job at teen
vogue as the editor chief right well the
people who work there wrote a letter
trying to get that editor-in-chief
cancelled for ten-year-old tweets
in response
it was uh a seven-figure ad deal was
pulled frozen the article said they lost
it then it said it was frozen because of
the controversy
so this this company teen vogue which is
supposed to be a fashion magazine and
now it's like writing about marx and
social justice and critical theory yeah
hires on people who are good at writing
about intersectionality because it gets
a lot of clicks
and then those people attack their own
company costing their own company seven
figures
so perhaps there's some optimism in all
of this in that these people are just
consuming themselves and what will
eventually just be a withered husk in
the corner of nothing yeah i mean that
that is actually the hope is that that's
that's sort of the the mentality behind
the people that are so-called
accelerationists
um they want to kind of encourage this
to happen faster or to get people to see
it um i'll just take the story that you
told just to kind of complete the since
we mentioned scholarship and that's what
i do i can plug the scholarship into
your story because the majority of those
people you know that you said they work
for a video game magazine or whatever
some of them did a lot of them are
freelancers
in both cases these people probably
studied something like media studies
especially the freelancers what was the
joke you know we're talking gamergate
was 2014 right yeah so what was the joke
the joke was um you know you get a
degree in something like gender studies
or media studies or something and you're
going to be a barista no well probably
you might be but you're also going to be
a freelancer because you think you're a
great writer and you have great insights
so what are they going to start writing
these sexist racists homophobic blah
blah blah you know keyword or articles
about well they're going to start
infusing that theory and then
various touch points happen in society
that then mainstream but what's
happening is these bloggers or freelance
journalists i should say are essentially
starting to infuse that theory into pop
culture and that theory has been
cranking for 50 years saying you know by
the way guys
society actually is secretly fascist
it's secretly racist it's secretly
sexist racism critical race theories
kind of central thesis could be boiled
down to racism never gets better it just
hides itself better and then you have
these little cutesy
you know
graduates and these stupid degrees
become freelance writers and then it's
keyword city right it's buzzword city
racist video game racist
movie racist dr seuss
racist your mom whatever it happens to
be
and uh one thing after another and then
these are the people who are poised to
write these little fluff piece
well they're like it's like the hit
version of a fluff piece right no
content it's like it's like a it's like
a bundle of thorns or something instead
of fluff but these are the people are
going to write these things and they
start injecting the ideas of systemic
racism and systemic sexism and all of
these kind of critical theory ideas into
the pop culture through those mediums
and that if you go way back i mean that
was actually gramsci's plan not to get
heavy in theory but antonio gramsci the
i'm supposed to always say albanian
italian i said that he was italian which
is true and these uh italian people
wrote me these emails are like call him
albanian italian please don't stick him
tell us
don't make it he was brilliant actually
the guy was probably one of the sharpest
minds of the 20th century unfortunately
he was also a communist and um he was
only realized that you have to underpin
or under you have to undermine the
pillars of culture in order to take over
a society and he identified those as
being in
religion family media education and law
so that media pillar that's what the
goal was he said what you have to do is
you have to get inside if you want to
take a pillar of culture down you get
inside of it you create a counter
hegemony within the existing hegemony
and start making it grow and basically
when you say parasite that's what you're
talking about it's get latch on and then
grow the strength of that thing like
like a sith or something i don't know
i'm not a star wars you're the one with
the torches
but
um
i mean that's the idea right is to get
in there and to start infusing these
critical ideas this is a plan that's
been like cooking up scholarly for a
hundred years that had actually no real
way to work until all of a sudden we
cooked up this i've been thinking about
this a lot lately in the last i don't
know three months social media and then
i don't know what to call it but like
just kind of like grubby media you know
like
you know little
grubby articles like these different
gawker was like just a propaganda place
or whatever it got taken down games of
telephone articles that regurgitate the
same thing written by somebody else grub
media called journalism journalism yeah
or urinalism according to jeremy hanby
the quartering today
you said that the sith were parasitic i
like that because the sith apprentice
parasite off the master grows strong and
then kills the master
i mean it's
right there i mean it's like the whole
plan it's basically you know emperor
palpatine
taking over becoming the chancellor and
everyone cheers for it
i mean there you go but i'm not i'm i'm
convinced more and more regular people
hate all of this oh totally i would bet
i was talking to somebody the other day
about it and somebody said the the guy
said
i think that we are in the majority and
i was like we're not just in a majority
we're not even in a super majority i bet
it's north of 90 percent yeah
north of 90 of people at best to the
degree that they're aware of it are
annoyed by it or insulted by it or i
think it's ridiculous and cowardly but
that's the problem yeah i'll um i'll get
to a point where i have a clear mind
i'll wake up in the morning and i'll put
on like facebook or something
i'll feel like i'm being twisted and
destroyed into some dark tunnel and i'll
have to stop and put it away and leave i
mean that's why i used to call i mean
it's a formal term that comes out of
jacques derrida postmodern philosophy
but i used to call twitter a
deconstruction machine it deconstructs
anything you put you put you know for
myself a video of myself using a sword
immediately people add benny benny hill
music and try to make a joke out of it
like like you can't make a joke out of
something i think is awesome like it's
just not gonna work like i know i look
awesome just shut up you know somebody
changed it into an eggplant a giant
eggplant instead of a giant sword i'm
like i just downloaded that and like
that's like a meme i share now but yeah
it's fun but no anything you put on the
internet is going on twitter on social
media i should say not the internet is
going to get uh i'm so stuck on the
german now it's going to get alph get
hoping almost immediately is going to
get deconstructed it's going to get
taken apart it's going to get um going
to get turned into this dialectical
soup where it gets chewed up and spit
back at you into broken pieces like you
said that eventually go into they become
the grist that goes into that um closed
circle of garbage media and this is
actually the process because that crap
on twitter becomes the article that
becomes your wikipedia page right yeah i
actually made some food like this once i
have a meat processor and i put in a
nice fine steak and then i put in some
some fish and some chicken and it became
a goop and then i fed all the goop right
back in and then i fed all the goop
right back in it became a grayish paste
and that's basically what it is totally
i have no idea what it is but apparently
you're supposed to eat it it's chicken
nuggets chicken nuggets well i mean it
was just meat medley meat punch the
wikipedia thing though you're absolutely
right dude you know it was on my
wikipedia for a while like my wiki i
have a new it's fairly new i've only had
a wikipedia entry for a few months and
like right off the bat somebody
said like i'm like my wikipedia said you
know james lindsay portrays himself as a
serious commentator he wrote a book how
to have impossible conversations and yet
he goes on twitter and makes your mom
jokes
that was on my wikipedia yeah and then
that got taken off and then somebody
else i don't know who put it i'm
assuming a fan of mine went on and put
that james lindsay has gigantic balls of
brass like yeah there you go that was on
my wikipedia for a while like
this you know about wikipedia is the the
the me i'm i'm actually i've
this is probably bad in the in the
bigger picture but i'm i'm here for it
dude do you know the zeppelin story uh
for like seven years
my wikipedia claimed that i invented a
zeppelin
some kind of autonomous flying camera on
a zeppelin and it was because i guess
there was some writer who overheard just
like uh we were having like a
hackerspace kind of conversation about
crazy ideas and then somehow they wrote
that i actually invented a zeppelin
and then it that's it it's fact and no
matter how many times i was like bro i
didn't invent a zeppelin man it's like
we're talking about i bought a consumer
drone and me and my buddy hacked the
drone to broadcast live footage during
occupy wall street it was like one of
the first times i think maybe the first
time there was a live news broadcast via
drone we were working for a big
corporation so it was just online but it
was amazing i was like flying a drone
over this occupy protest and then it
couldn't fly that long we talked about a
bunch of crazy ideas and apparently an
article came out that was total bs that
wouldn't correct it and didn't want to
correct it because it was a fun story
and then wikipedia was like tim pool
invented a drone and i was like i didn't
and they're like too bad you're not
reliable so you know what
i'm here for it i think i thought that
was the tim that was the tim poole blimp
is what that was right yeah or the good
tim blimp it said zeppelin it said
literally said zeppelin modification or
something so so look tim zepplin i wanna
i want to preserve the the important
cultural institutions that have helped
bring about civil rights
real social justice but at this point i
think the entire system it's already
falling apart the gender the jenga tower
is in free fall that's the perfect
metaphor it's these guys are just
knocking
pegs out and it's only a matter of time
the thing falls down so you think it's
acceleration
maybe a little bit but not necessarily
it's very targeted i think i know where
you're where you're going well here's
what i'm going to say
uh wikipedia is is fundamentally broken
and it it's it's extremely susceptible
to attack right now yeah uh but there's
there's a there is a
i wouldn't call it accelerationism but
an opportunity to prove the paradox
well so so here's what happened right i
tweeted impeach the queen we talked
about the other night and a news guard
certified website wrote an article
saying tim poole calls for the
impeachment of queen elizabeth people
supported him saying let's convene
congress like this person who wrote it
was one of the worst journalists
imaginable didn't understand you can't
impeach the queen that congress has no
power even if you could to interfere
with another country's monarch wrote the
article and then here's the best part on
wikipedia they're actually arguing over
whether or not it should be included and
for a while somebody put it in and they
started taking like tim pool has called
you know in in 2021 tim poole called for
the impeachment of queen elizabeth and
then people are like we have to put it
in and people are like you can't put it
in and then someone actually linked the
video where i was laughing saying i made
the whole thing up i know how this
system works and i can make a joke and
then wikipedia must treat it as fact
so you have one faction saying we know
he's basically you know screwing around
and it was a joke tweet there's a wink
like a wink meme on it and then someone
saying we don't have the right to choose
what we determine is true or false
that's original research and it's banned
on wikipedia you have to go by the
sources and newsguard has certified the
source a whole thing is broken that's
totally broken redickypedia that's the
name of this project
what you're working on a project no i'm
just telling you that's the name of your
project read pediatrics isn't it
ridiculous you you you talk about how
twitter and this is the deconstruction
it's like a counter deconstruction like
they want to build a counter hegemony i
want to do a counter deconstruction so
there's a lot of journalists who will
write whatever you tweet as law and so
if you engage on twitter seriously and
and say things that you actually mean
they'll write articles about what you
say or they'll take things out of
context to make it worse
so as far as i'm concerned i'm all for
biden baby 100 percent oh who's 20 24 go
by
i'm tweeting things like
you know
i believe in you joe i treated one hour
like if we all cheer for joe maybe he'll
send us the next 600 i believe in you
and so at a certain point you have to do
jazz hands for joe well here's the
important thing
all of my tweets are 100 serious that's
it that's all i care about um
i think i think i've crafted a strategy
that creates a paradox that cannot be
countered in any reasonable capacity
i'm sure there will be attempts but the
ultimate issue is this i tweeted abolish
the atf i tweeted abolish the irs which
one of those if any are my actual
opinions
i also tweeted
you know uh there was a study saying
that you know fauci says something like
coveted lockdowns
we or they said something like we don't
know if there's ever going to be an end
to the pandemic and so then i said okay
then release all the restrictions
there's actual opinions in there which
one's the real one
maybe you can come to one of my you know
podcast and try and figure out how i
really feel about things do i really
want to abolish the atf
i said abolishing the police is wrong
what's my real opinion go ahead and
figure it out journalists you won't be
able to which means any tweet ever used
by any publication from me will be them
publishing complete bunk bs because you
will not be able to determine which one
of my tweets is real yeah i do this only
i change my name when i do it you know i
often change my name on twitter so this
is inspiring me by the way i got to
change my name on twitter back to king
of your mom so that some journalist puts
out my wikipedia but he really does
think he's the king of your mom um but
because i am but no uh i changed my name
though to lame's jinzy lame's jinzy is
my troublemaking like if i'm going to
say you know very smart opinions if i'm
a virgin james lindsay is is a
deplorable or something now and so lames
jinzy is my very smart person persona um
he has all the correct opinions but but
but by doing that you're making sure
they know which one is the real and
which one is the no no the the the
problem here is that when you change
your name it changes your name on all
your rights so i do it and i make the
tweets and like an hour later it doesn't
make any sense so then they i have the
same paradox i just
throw a wink and a nod to my uh peeps
that actually pay close attention to me
i'm also going to tweet a lot of nice
things about lefties good just to be
nice
you know but it's really i mean it's my
favorite thing to tweet about lefties is
like
you know
is what what the president said i don't
know which president a president some
president said that you can't hate the
haters and losers you got to love them
because they can't help that they were
born after up
[Laughter]
that's true
i mean it does help even to win a war if
you love the enemy you'll be better
served at destroying them you know if
you were fighting them i look at it this
way
you know i i was approaching everything
wrong for the longest time i knew that
my word was meaningless for wikipedia
and for these journalists there was uh
like the zeppelin thing should have been
a really strong wake-up call for me no
matter how many times i kept screaming i
didn't make a zeppelin people were like
the guardian i think was the guardian
that wrote it so like shut up you're not
allowed and so it's like okay why don't
i just give ridiculous quotes to
journalists
and let them write things and then have
that be
could you imagine the historical record
uh i did that to zach beauchamp whenever
he interviewed me about the grievance
studies affair he called me and it was
like the most leading conversation ever
he was like wow that's very interesting
i learned something new i had no idea
that was true could you tell me a lot
more about that you know
and i was like i'm just going to plant
quotes and see what he see what he
publishes
and he wrote the best article ever i
love it i mean it terrible it's it's
awful to me but it's so funny because i
know what i said and i know what i was
like nonsense he published things i
wanted him to publish right so i owned
him and he doesn't even to this day he
has no idea that i absolutely item on
that article i think there's two things
people can do they don't realize become
active on wikipedia and then
the interesting thing was watching
people on wikipedia who are like they
have legitimate accounts and their
long-standing editors are going over the
philosophy and merits and the rules of
wikipedia and it just be becomes
absolute it's it's bedlam like you can't
use original research but tim poole
admitted it i don't care if he admitted
it and they're just fighting yeah this
is what you're going to do because i
mean it reduces wikipedia to absurd them
like it's not even like it's an
unreliable source like all your college
professors might have told you or your
high school teachers or whoever it's
like it's actually
it's actually just reduced to absurdity
yep yeah my one of my favorite things is
that like i haven't taken twitter
seriously in a really long time oh no
that's that's key you can't take too i
mean the second you take twitter
seriously you're doing it wrong all
these people are mad at me like what are
you doing on twitter i'm like having fun
it's like a sewer pipe like as fun as a
sewer pipe i mean it's not like that's
what i used to say it says information
out which may be the form of whatever
you want to send through it was a sewer
that followed you back in the day but my
other buddy said no it's more like a
dumpster fire you pack up in a backpack
and take with you and i thought that was
the best way to do it
accelerationism i think is the wrong is
the wrong idea typically people use it
to refer to like physical chaos and
violence and stuff but i think like
screwing with the press to
prove
that the failures and the paradox of
these systems i wouldn't call that
accelerationism i would i would call
that like
it's almost like sabotage it's almost
like it is you can sabotage can be a
form of acceleration like if a dam is
cracking and you're like dude that
damn's gonna break and kill millions of
people so you go and you smash the dam
you accelerate what's going to happen
anyway because you're like let's just
get it over with well so you're the one
that's blamed for destroying the damn
i'm not talking about it
what i'm talking about is
so long as the media goes unchecked it
will not be a damn that's about to break
it will last forever and it will grow
and they make lots of money i think it
has to break eventually don't you no
crazy culture or war i mean until they
drive people to kill each other my usual
answer with that is
the truth is always going to win in the
end right so it will break but the
soviet union lasted 70 years
i don't think that's a long time of such
i don't think the truth though
i think the winner of the war writes the
history
i mean reality is still going to bat
last you could the lie only maintain so
long and what if whether you know what
actually happened or not is a different
question but the the the damn which i'm
thinking of it as as the ability to
continue maintaining the lie
um that will give
and
it will eventually the truth will out
and but the problem is is that you know
a like i said the the soviet union
lasted 70 years of not that good
to put it mildly and the china is still
going yeah um it's been a long time it's
still not great and uh simultaneously
you know when you're talking about
something like a cultural revolution
which is frankly what we're in the midst
of
accelerationism can push people like
you're talking about a damn breaking and
millions of people dying yes
tens of millions of people died in the
cultural revolution you are correct and
accelerating toward that rather than
trying to figure out a way to divert the
course of the river um is probably not
the best strategy i have an analogy
it's like you're in a car right and
you're like on a on an abandoned train
track and you can see that up ahead the
bridge is out and if you try and slow
down you might just go off the cliff but
if you slam that gas baby you could jump
the gorge and then or
reach what 88 miles an hour that's what
i'm gonna say you gotta hit 88 miles per
hour and then back in time when the
bridge was still there yeah yeah no no
forward in time
when the bridge was completely even
better
but you need to have like a pack
actually that's a really interesting
that in back to the future the bridge
wasn't there yet and they hit 88 and
then hit the future where the bridge did
exist and it wasn't about going super
fast it was just the right speed so
nobody died there was no destruction so
perhaps if we if oh no the train went
off though and blew up you're right
there was some destruction so maybe but
the train was blowing up anyway because
that crazy chemist put those um pink
logs in there that were blowing its
gaskets and stuff right so wait wait
great so so here's the announcement 21
gigawatts we're all in the woke train
and if we don't get it to the right
speed
the delorean won't make it to the future
where the bridge is complete and we can
all live peacefully but the woke train
is going to go off no matter what that's
correct actually i think that's a good
one
that was like pop culture reference i
was like this is going right off the
gorge the whole no and then it landed
you landed that tim these there's a lot
of progressive pundits get really
triggered by by pop culture references
yeah i'm like you know like you don't
have to like it i don't care probably a
lot of people might not like it point 21
gigawatts well right regular people
understand pop culture and it's
interesting to me who are these
progressives who like don't watch movies
and don't watch tv shows and like are
not part of culture maybe that's why
they're in this weird space where they
believe these weird things uh
they're sad
how fun is it talk about back to the
future it was way better great movie
totally it was fun that was christmas
that was three three was great well
that's the thing yeah christopher lloyd
he's incredible he's good hey do you
okay so we're talking about
accelerationism the cancel the culture
war do you think that it's like a
chinese or a communist intentional plot
to subvert the political structure one
of
many that this guy what was the guy's
name the albanian guy oh antonio gramsci
this communist conceptual artist antonio
gramsci gramsci um do you think they're
using that philosophy now to try and
undercut american society um
yes and no more yes than no
the infiltration of the institutions and
the establishment of a counter-hegemony
and a counter-state uh which the uh
peeps in the on the right call a deep
state is certainly something that's been
an objective uh that's been explicit by
the radical left intelligentsia
it was definitely adopted by big players
like herbert marcus in the 1960s and
you're like who
he was a rock star he had huge
followings you're talking 1960s and he
could like pack a house at 300 000 you
know
sales of his book in the first like
couple of years that came out or
something in the 60s so this is a he was
a rock star on the left he was mentored
to angela davis we're talking about blm
and wow prison stuff he was he was her
phd mentor at ucsd
and so it's like he's not a french
figure
um
and he deliberately said in the 1960s
that it's time for the leftist
intelligentsia and the universities to
start teaming up with the cultural
outsiders
and the racial minorities specifically
to form
kind of a block that would operate in a
in kind of unison by the racial
minorities who didn't of course mean
racial minorities what he meant was the
radicalizable black liberationists who
were operating within his paradigm which
was the paradigm that was identified by
the communist party in the 20s and 30s
as the wedge issue that would open
america so there is an element to where
it's very deliberate now your typical
woke person
never heard of any of this has no idea
they're just trying to be a good person
they put their black square on their
instagram
they're like but i do care about racism
and they have no idea about any of it
your typical professor
of gender studies probably has a dim
idea at best maybe hasn't even ever
heard of gramsci so um
probably has no idea that this actually
was a communist plot although they're
going to still say you know down with
capitalism down with capitalism on my
flight in here i was actually reading
herbert marcus's
essay on liberation which was written in
1969
and he's just like
all through it he's like you know
what we have to do is abolish capitalism
in order to make room for socialism so
this was certainly something that was in
that line of thought
all the way back you know in the 60s and
was deliberately implanted into the the
scholarly literature uh very in the
universities very intentionally then so
there is an intentional aspect to it
um it's also modeled after what we are
experiencing as a cultural revolution
you know you brought up china
the chinese had a cultural revolution
the 66 through 76 or 65 through 75 or
something like that
it was pa the wave for that was paved i
know mao was his own special kind of
character but the way for that was paved
with the same rhetoric as we see in
critical race theory
applied to the han race instead of the
white race talked about han supremacy
starting in the 1920s in china started
talking about some people were good hans
and some people were han supremacists
like separating all the rhetoric
mirrors um really closely uh exactly
what's going on and they started to
create basically racial disharmony
throughout china and then that was kind
of part of the grounds upon which that
instability that mao was able to step in
who
when you say though is your typical
critical race theorist a marxist well
some of them are i mean you had the
founders of black lives matter come out
and say you know we're trained marxists
they got caught on video saying that
was that patricia collins i don't think
they were caught on saying i think
they're proudly saying well i know they
probably was like a public thing yeah i
mean it's it's def and if you read their
website before they described it it was
like comrades this black lives matter
fist is actually just the communist fist
right yeah it's not even the black lives
matter fest but people call it that
right i mean that's exactly right it is
it is just a communist fist
so there's something very deliberate
there but again your average critical
race theorists
may not know very much of this because
they're just caught up in the theory uh
just going along with the theory so
there's like this lack of intentionality
but then you say who's funding this
who's dumping the of course the
universities are giving it space but
who's funding this and you start looking
at the various you know huge
organizations that are funding this
throwing
billions of dollars into it uh you have
for example
kimberly crenshaw is one of the cr she
is the creator of intersectionality she
was one of the creators of critical race
theory she was a
she cites angela davis who we just
mentioned as a student marcusa
well she runs this thing called the
african-american poly policy forum
that's almost completely funded by the
open society foundation this is one of
these big billionaire philanthropists
that's basically dumping money into this
that's a george soros that's soros yeah
what's the agenda there it was he a
communist well i don't know i have no
idea mackenzie bezos also put two
billion dollars into critical theory
yeah i mean tons of them i mean the the
oregon ethnic studies ethnic math
program that just made headlines
everywhere where they were like focusing
on the right answers white supremacy
culture
two plus two is five two plus two well
that one's not in there but it's it's in
the wheelhouse yeah but ethnomathematics
for the state of oregon which just got
pushed through by law i think into their
schools
that's funded by bill and melinda gates
the whole program was funded by the bill
melinda gates foundation and so it's
like there are are they is bill and
melinda are they communists i mean it's
like i don't know i don't think so maybe
um
i don't know what's a good word for
people like that you know like um
megalomaniac i mean megalomaniac is
usually usually kind of the thing right
it's people who think that they have the
capacity to just step in and do good
like
and it's like the bad guy in the movie
they know how to or yeah
i'm glad you brought that up
isn't that film just a bit on the nose
yeah like they even make the my fair
lady reference what's that okay so you
you know you know the story my fair lady
right it was like a woman was like a
[ __ ] or something yeah yeah eliza
doolittle and so this is written by
george bernard shaw it was actually
originally titled pygmalion and modeled
after the pygmalion myth but we don't
have to go into pygmalion
so eliza doolittle is this
[ __ ] basically
and these two rich guys find her and
they're like i have a bet you know and
they're gonna they're gonna bring her in
and teach her her manners well enough to
fake it and if she can get to the end of
this you know fancy dinner at the end of
a certain amount of time and convince
everybody that she's not basically a
flower girl which i think is what it
actually is she's selling flowers or
something and that's of course a symbol
for something um
then you know one or the other wins the
bet and it's all this gentleman's better
whatever
and so that's what my fair lady is about
so that was written though by george
bernard shaw who was the leader of the
fabian socialists which had the
crest of a wolf in sheep's clothing
and it had the explicit uh agenda if you
could look up their they have a stained
glass window it's very famous called the
the fabian glass or the fabian window
and uh it actually says something like
it shows the world heated up on a forge
set on an anvil and they're hitting it
with hammers and one of the people
hitting it is george bernard shaw and
it's like
heat it up and remold it to the heart's
desire or something like that uh so
they're trying to reshape the world and
they were socialist and the goal was
incremental sneaking and if socialism
wolf and sheep's clothing so that people
don't realize what you're doing it says
remold it nearer to the heart's desire
yeah that's what it says that's right
devoutly hammer stoutly wow yeah so this
is this is actually a really famous
piece of glass the the the fabian
society is not well known now it i think
still exists it spun off the labor party
in the uk and probably the other labor
parties it also spun off the london
school of economics which is probably
it's kind of main operating base of
think tanks now
and
the reference like at the very beginning
of kingsman you know you have again this
kind of like roughneck
essex
cockney kid right and he's just like all
kinds of in trouble because he grew up
without his dad his dad died in the
thing
and uh he has a special like king's been
thing if he ever gets in trouble and
he's always going around and horsing
around getting in trouble he's and he's
a his foul mouth it's really kind of
funny the way he talks you know eggsy is
his name yeah and then he ends up
getting in trouble and he calls and it's
like these gentlemen appear and now
they're going to make him into
a gentleman warrior yeah secret service
agent gentlemen spy and you know the
movie's hilarious it's really worth
watching it's it's like a
semi's i don't know it's not even
semi-serious it's spoof off of like
james bond type stuff it's it's it's
pretty serious but it's pretty serious
too yeah but like it kind of it plays
into the silliness of the gentleman's
bio right and so the theme of the first
there's two of the two films and the
theme of the first film though you have
uh is it samuel jackson yeah is playing
this megalomaniac cell phone
company big tech mogul
um vincent valentine or something
something valentine uh i forgot his
first name and he basically has decided
that we are the virus and the planet is
going to die from global global warming
and so he devises this technology that
he will that can make people go insane
and kill each other uh
if they hear a noise and so what he
offers is everybody in the world gets
free cell phones free sim cards free
internet forever or whatever so
everybody goes to get their free sim
cards and then he plays the sound when
everybody has them
and everybody starts killing each other
everywhere they are
and uh to kill to bring down the global
population so that and it's like but the
[ __ ] in this movie stops him and saves
all the people well that's right that's
exactly right so is that kind of like
defying
shaw's you know
story i mean
i watch this and i'm just i mean but the
point of course i just brought up shaw
because they they they referenced the
movie right right and so
or the reference the play i should say
my fair lady what i mean is in the movie
the bad guy is the guy who wants to kill
all the people to stop global warming
correct
using a high-tech media device right
makes people crazy which is super on the
nose exactly and the the good guy is the
regular person who
didn't want to be involved and got
dragged in and found an opportunity and
then says i'm going to stop these people
and save the ones that i love oh right a
regular guy who along the way learns
manneth manners maketh man yeah right so
that's like their like little line of
the gentleman warrior or spy or whatever
but yeah so
the the question i watch this and i'm
like
did the people who wrote this film know
like they made the my fair lady
reference did they know about the fabian
socialists the plan of the fabian
socialists they know where this is like
what could be going on here
are they tapped into the idea that we're
using media devices like that in our
pocket it's not noisy is this social
media to drive ourselves nuts and hate
each other have you seen um what's that
uh what's that tv show
the the the virus one oh uh utopia
utopia yeah you've seen utopia i have
not but they can't
know why they canceled it uh two on the
nose yep yep whoa the show is about a uh
there's these people and spoiler it's an
old show but they remade it on amazon
the amazon remix apparently got
cancelled because it was two on the nose
uh
let me explain that but you know let me
explain they there's a comic book and in
the comic there's clues to what's really
going on to put it simply a piece of
visual entertainment
gives a group of people for knowledge as
to what's really going on and what's
really going to happen
as it turns out
this tech mogul guy who thinks that
we're overpopulated and the planet is
destroying itself
stages of pandemic
and then offers up everybody a vaccine
which sterilizes them
and they canceled it because they were
like
yeah no
and so the point was conspiracy
theorists were saying
a piece of visual entertainment
that we can watch
is talking about a virus
that's being staged you know that's that
where where a tech mogul is pushing a
vaccine
a little on the nose with what's going
on right now and so you you have it you
have a show they're reading a comic
learning the future
or what's the pla what the plan is the
code names tech mogul well we got a bill
gates we got a covet 19. we got a
vaccine program and we got it free for
everybody and so they were like you know
stuff that's not the show yeah and the
original version of it actually was back
in like i think 2011 or something in the
uk ooh yeah
i mean so i mean life imitates art i
guess do you ever see that video game
plague inc
incorporated it was like the object it's
still super popular yeah well it got
banned in china right after kovid they
banned it but the point of the game is
you're playing as a virus or a pathogen
of some sort and you want to infect all
of humanity and destroy them and so
after china banned the game some time
went by they were like we feel really
bad about this they just released their
expansion the cure so now you play as a
doctor trying to vaccinate and stop the
the plague uh it's free for everyone
until kovitz done by the way
yeah so good bad i don't know but super
keyed into the manipulation of media
that's for sure you know there's a
gender studies paper that's titled
women's studies as a virus right
is that yours i know
no this one's real it's by michael
karger and bran fawz
and they actually argue that the virus
makes the ideal metaphor for feminists
and women studies and gender studies
pedagogy and they say that what what it
should be is that people are being
infected in their disciplines and by
maybe minoring in the subject or
whatever and then going off into
graduate school to infect other
disciplines and then they compare
themselves yes i kid you not they
compare themselves favorably to
all of hiv ebola and cancer
wow they compare their own discipline
favorably they say hiv is immune
suppressing and so you want to be you
have to take up steps that make you
immune suppressing because it's a very
effective virus ebola is extraordinarily
powerful and dangerous and contagious
and cancer represents i'm not joking
they talk about viruses entering cells
maybe like the hpv or whatever and
changing the dna in the cell and then
that leads to cancer and they said that
represents permanent transformational
change
of disciplines and and other departments
and other walks of life and affinities
cancer that's how they want a permanent
you know i wish i would they literally
call themselves cancer hiv and ebola wow
i wish the grand conspiracies were real
sometimes because life's not boring i
mean it's like and it's probably just
you look for panic i think they are
sometimes that's the crazy part yeah i
like gulf of tonka and we know that yeah
we do know that for a fact i mean for
admission anyway yeah mostly for uh
i think there is still some you know
pushback sometimes these crazy
conspiracies are real which makes life
worth living i mean it's just so
interesting it also makes life very
dangerous if you look into certain
things like state street black rock and
uh what's that other big investment firm
there's like three investment firms that
run the earth basically right uh black
stuff is it black the real
yeah yeah at some point and this is true
a lot of people realize because i've
actually i've actually talked to uh
politicians who've said this
it's called vanguard vanguard blackrock
states vanguard vanguard biggest
investment firm in the world i've
actually met politicians who say it's
sometimes better to have the power in
the shadows than it is to be the public
face and so a lot of politicians are
performative they're there to entertain
and keep stability in the sense that
like
it's it's almost like
you know with the coliseum of rome
people were suffering they were hungry
there was chaos there was corruption so
give them fights and throw bread out
bread in circuses right
well now they're effectively doing that
in congress you'd see for the longest
time these politicians yelling like you
know my colleague over there across the
aisle just hates everybody and i'm sick
of it and then once it's over like you
see the camera is like you know the the
the the uh the actual news network would
pull away but actually on in in the
senate they'd like walk over they walk
over and shake hands because in the back
c-span never turns off but nobody like
nobody's watching it yeah you'd watch
them shake hands and grab a drink
together and be hanging out and laughing
and it was like all a performance
because there are people they they keep
the the people in this country divided
to a certain degree
and i i you know maybe it's on purpose
maybe it's not but it's actually what
this what the machine does whether
whether these politicians intentionally
do it i'm sure a lot of people would say
they would the machine does it
regardless
right the the city people and the rural
people are divided even in red states
blue like small towns are blue it's the
weirdest thing i was in rural west
virginia and i drove through a tiny town
and it was all critical race theory and
i was like i just drove like a mile away
and it was all trump signs but in a
small town where you had proximity more
density it was like black lives matter
flags and stuff so you think they're
playing performance these politicians
because it's too dangerous to go deep on
like the real issues no the real
companies like vanguard i think i think
no i think the problem is they don't
care they don't pay attention that might
be true so it's an easy opportunity for
those with massive power to just keep
gaining power no one will stop them i
mean kennedy got killed i don't know if
it was a political coup or not but the
dude was speaking out against the
military industrial complex and got
killed that sucked so
in not since have any president ever
come out trumps the military yeah he did
a little actually not really no he
didn't really yeah i mean a little bit
weapons deal he acknowledged it but he
didn't like do anything he wasn't saying
i'm gonna break it up he was all in
favor of the weapons deals because of
the money but he's not in favor of the
war because he promised to end it and so
it wasn't
perhaps the uh uh if you believe in the
conspiracies it wasn't a kill worthy
thing it was like he's still selling our
weapons we're getting money
using drone bombers
how do we sell more if he's not using
them you know what i mean so they didn't
like that they wanted more war
but he wasn't like overtly like i'm
gonna break up the military-industrial
complex like kennedy said he was very
overt about it well fearless
so
back to the uh the china question no
well so uh i i we had china uncensored
on the show i asked him about this and
i'm wondering are you familiar with
thucydides trap
uh yeah vaguely basically like we're
facing a potential war with china based
on historical precedent i'm wondering if
we're already actually we're already in
it you know a lot of people might want
might not want to acknowledge this but
cyber war between us and china has been
pretty intense for a long time let me
just draw back to that word political
war right political warfare has been
happening um the the
biggest sign that i ever saw with that
was the chinese have a term to make fun
of the woke which is by
yes
yeah it means it means white left and
white left it does yeah and then all of
a sudden like the the wumau accounts on
twitter or yeah twitter stopped making
fun of them it's like all of a sudden it
was like it's not making fun of him and
then the accounts were like america has
a big systemic racism problem yeah yep
and it's like all of a sudden they
realize that this is a weapon
um because they used to make fun of the
white left yeah well now it's now they
can see that it's destroying the country
and they should embolden it was mao's
revolution a form of political war in
the beginning
uh i mean yeah they were engaging in
political warfare for sure the the goal
with the cultural revolution was kind to
cover up for the failure of the great
great leap forward so that mao could
reclaim power so the great leap forward
was when he took all the farmers out of
the farms yeah and he took all the
farmers and said you guys are gonna all
make steel because steel is the one big
measurement yeah and they all ended up
making crappy pig iron and nobody was
growing food and
so command economy baby it was like the
great leap into the dumpster is what it
worked out to be a great leap into 50
million dead people pretty much okay
that's not funny not so funny but um
yeah so that was a huge failure and they
actually kind of chased mao out of power
uh and i'm not real sharp on the the
chinese history with remembering who all
the names are in the gang of four and
all of this stuff but then mao came back
with
basically with his little red book
indoctrinating students and young people
in universities and schools
and uh unleashed what he called the red
guard in the cultural revolution to
destroy the four olds of society
and you know old habits old ideas old
customs old ways of thinking what do you
think is happening right now
it's like you know dr seuss was a man of
his time we have to destroy that his
time was terrible
um thomas jefferson was a man of his
time throw a statue in the lake
abraham lincoln man of his time
take the name off the school and and san
francisco throw his statue in the lake
too you know right right like the antifa
a or whatever it is on on his face with
spray paint uh yeah anarchy
which apparently they don't understand
what that means no i love this people
claiming to be yeah right yeah exactly
that's a better one yeah
authoritarianism by the way in that
essay just to
not to dive into this but essan
liberation i was reading uh you
repeatedly have markus refer to the the
need to raise the the flag the red and
the black flag that's what he's always
referring to throughout that in case you
wonder like who he's connected to yeah
what's that the fascist and the
communist flag no no red and black is uh
left anarchy yeah it's a it's a symbol
of what is it black is labor yes and red
is
red
yeah it's socialism and anarchy is what
it is yeah yeah um and then there's
black and yellow that's why luke luke
really likes black and yellow but that's
capitalism that's that fan yeah right
that's the fancy symbol of antifa has a
black and a red flag that's that's what
it is yeah and so he's referring to that
in 1969 it's like empowering the black
and the red the even says the black and
the red flag must be empowered behind
this and it's like huh
yeah anti-fascist
acton or however it said in german my
german pronunciation is not very good
you know what the berlin wall's real
name was no the anti-fascist protection
rampart
that was the actual name of the berlin
wall
which is called the berlin wall because
that's the colloquial name that's the
common name but i think it's important
we remember what the true name was yeah
exactly i mean this is the thing so i
was reading bella dodd's testimony again
i read it
in december or november last year and i
was reading it again a little bit today
and a little bit last week
and
bella dot was a member of the communist
party usa who confessed and or she
actually left the party defected and in
1953 she confessed everything basically
about the communist party's ideas to the
house committee on american activities
now known as the house judiciary
committee
and uh well not quite it assumed all of
that former committee's roles and duties
which are technically not dissolved
but she's confessing and she says you
will always find i put this on twitter
just yesterday or the day before you'll
always find
that the communist plan is to dress up
its activities in high
high-minded terms so you'll find the
communists saying that we are the
anti-fascists right and so if you oppose
communism you must be pro-fascist
and that was a she was saying this in
the 1950s about how i'm gonna know i'm
an anti-republican
i mean good i mean i have those memes
about becoming an anti-republican yeah
yeah see i'm an anti-republican that and
that means i believe in free speech it
means i believe in you know the right of
the individual to assemble the
constitution and if you oppose me you're
pro-republican yeah that's the problem
yeah yeah exactly i'm glad you
understand the logic the communists
would say um rightists they hunted down
the rightists they did brightest intent
rightist beliefs this was big with mao
uh also of course bourgeois but um but
they did go right after rightist it's
too naked but i mean marcus put that his
essay repressive tolerance from 1965 the
thesis statement like is literally
almost word for word
movements from the left must be
tolerated under all circumstances
movements from the right must not be
tolerated what terrifies me is when i
find myself saying people on the left i
feel like i've been indoctrinated and am
subconsciously being used as a pawn to
segregate this culture war no that's
true what needs to be done is that the
the willful actors who are participating
in this need their own identifiable name
that actually sticks woke is a thing but
it's slangy right um critical social
justice is the term that shows up in
their literature but it's scholarly
you know we could get really technical
it's a critical constructivist that's
what they're fighting mongooses that's a
good team name yeah i know right yeah
that's not too bad flying eagles um
but i i don't know
you know what exactly to call them the
repressive left would work but people
have tried variations it was regressive
left for a long time repressive is
actually more let's call them
identitarians identitarians is good yeah
the identity marxists fits um i i think
an editarian works because uh it's the
core ideology for a lot of what they
what they push
and
google search what identitarian means
and then you know yeah authoritarian i
like a lot too if you think about it but
it's identitarian these are people who
want they want law based on race yeah
they want law and policy based on
identity that's better because if we
think of it as left then they'll use
that yeah and then hunt people down
right and it's easy to be be opposed to
racism in all its forms right yeah
racism is wrong in all its forms is a
very powerful uh simple statement that
also has the concept of
robert lifton what are called
thought-stopping technique which
is what they use on you all the time
when they call you a racist they're
using thought-stopping techniques
lyfton was by the way describing how mao
was able to use the red guard to take
over uh when he talked about cult
cults being built uh he's specifically
analyzing the maoist one they're gonna
put half a million dollars into this
autonomous zone apparently
i don't know what that means did they
say what it was for or no it's gfas yeah
that's cool i'm not gonna lie stepping
out of the system for a minute gfaz
sounds cool but you want to go down and
hang out at the g fest i don't know i
guess i gotta shoot me so i'm not going
oh never mind
yeah journalists showed up and they were
like something bad's about to happen
right now he's like i'm okay we're
leaving yeah that's true she's a loser
yeah if this journalist shows up he's
like what do you mean i'm outside and
they're like you better leave i'd be
like shut your mouth kid go home again
make it happen that's a decision dilemma
too there you go put in a decision
dilemma yep and they the people are
cowards wait what do you mean what's the
decision dilemma you're you have to
either show weakness or you have to
overreact interesting when they get up
in your face in there you could you
better get out of here well i was
actually talking about the uh just the
establishment of an autonomous zone at
all they're right they're they're
basically playing chicken with the city
oh yeah if the city overreacts they're
going to be like help fascists this is
why we need clown block
clown block yeah is that like bat
anti-shark spray 100 people dressing
clowns just dancing and playing music
and like banging drums and like you know
because there's there's no aggression
there's no attack there's no affiliation
it's it's bizarre and it occupies space
and sully's their ideology that's very
butlerian
listen
if you send in a group of proud boys
it's horrifying white supremacists
attacking poor black lives matter
protesters so my friend told me that the
proud boys should all put on
like they should march socially
distanced on purpose they should all
wear rainbow masks they should have like
you know like the the the feminist power
fist like in the circle with the plus on
their like emblazoned on their chest or
whatever and they should go in singing
like john lennon's imagine and then just
see what happens because that puts them
in a decision dilemma but sure but the
story would then be
uh far-right white supremacists troll
black people
what happens if a bunch of unnamed
unidentifiable clowns show up playing
music and banging drums and giving out
funnel cake and cotton candy 400
articles about the joker they'll just
say a bunch of clowns showed up and are
occupying the space and playing music
and when when they're asked about what
they're doing they just go
and then who are the clowns the people
that occupy the autonomous zone of
course exactly yeah they're all clowns
yeah john mason is just occupied by a
large group of clowns
that's it
each and every clown is unidentifiable
they're not a political faction they
have no political ideology their their
faces are painted and they're wearing
wigs they're not identifiable they don't
bring weapons they don't fight anybody
literally just clowns having fun riding
little tricycles and laughing and
hugging and dancing and what would
happen if a parade of clowns with
balloons got brutally beaten by antifa
it would be art that was watched for
millennia people would reference those
videos of the clowns being taken away in
handcuffs by who
in movies it would be terrifying
it's a decision
what can these groups do if clowns
occupy their space
peaceful happy go lucky friendly
family-friendly people there just to
have us bring a smile to people's faces
who may be sad this is this is you are
creating the decision dilemma back for
them right now look at actually what you
have to do no public announcements no
organization just a hundred clowns
showing up on a certain date
just to bring joy to people
joy and peace and love and uh funnel
cake of course anti-violence
and if you if you oppose the
anti-violence then you're pro-violence
that's right you'd have to sustain it to
really have an impact like seven seven
weeks of clowns
and they could always be the same clowns
but different people but you could do
this everywhere you could do it
everywhere
because
when you look at the black block with
what the activists do and they all wear
black you can't figure out who these
people are you don't necessarily know
what their ideology is or they want and
it's they do this on purpose so they
can't get caught when they commit crimes
yeah exactly how are you going to smear
a bunch of clowns
just a bunch of cliche dude i'm in it no
this is good this is this
it creates the necessary dynamic that
you have to do people ask me all the
time like what's basically the strategy
what kind of thing you have to do you
have to put that they're trying to put
you in a decision dilemma you have to
put them back in the decision dilemma
and mid-level violence you know what
happens how you do it one of these
leftists are just like a clown and throw
a molotov oh yeah that's true that's the
other thing because like i was talking
to a guy who wants a
like i can't build technologies and
maybe you guys can he was saying that
would be really helpful is if you have
like this app where even if it's just
anonymous that you know you know you
could type in your school board or
whatever like brown school board or
whatever and you could find a school
district and you could find out like
parents can go in and opt in anonymously
or whatever maybe there's a community
function maybe it's not but you could
actually just know there's like 90 other
parents in the school's school district
who oppose critical race theory so you
feel more emboldened to be able to speak
up and if you could connect with one
another even if it's anonymous at first
or whatever but i was like that's just
gonna get like activists are just gonna
make fake accounts and descend on that
like crazy right um maybe if it's like
you know just the yes there are people
here
you make it anonymous like you know yeah
no one can see your name so you can say
whatever you want right i mean that that
would have to be the case because the
second they find out who you are you
know there's trouble i don't think so i
think the only reason there's trouble is
because there's a hundred people 10 of
them are pointing you know the baseball
bat and the other 90 are like but no one
will have my back yeah well this is the
the odds aren't that good for them
actually the i've heard so many stories
now because i get like preferential
stories of this sort sent to me
i've heard so many stories where you
have a school district for example that
serves maybe five ten thousand families
total in a community
and
the people do some digging and find out
that it's a dozen activists 12 against
thousands right and i've had cases in
where there's been small cities in the
u.s
where
people on either like the city council
or whatever have contacted me and said
you know we did some digging you know
we're getting constant relentless
harassment and tons of comments on all
the message boards blah blah blah from
different accounts well they're all fake
it turns out there's like 20 people
only one of them is a constituent
because you have to have one to be able
to file stuff and it's what tipped them
off is like why is the same person file
everything right you know that requires
a constituent to file but it's like it's
the only one it looks like there's 400
people this happens to me on twitter all
the time so i tweet something about
hegel's philosophy like anybody cares
right
and uh
all of a sudden you know i could start
getting dunked on which is strange
enough it must be touching some wire and
then
i'm having like cartoon characters with
like 60 followers reply tweet to my
tweet getting 300 400 likes within an
hour or two like you can't tell me
that's organic
like that's not normal
i that's that's not normal twitter
behavior in any universe so i just don't
check notifications well no the point is
that what you actually have with a lot
of these activists is you have a
perception
that there are lots of them but what
there actually are very small numbers of
them usually with lots of accounts that
are are swarming in artificial fake ways
to make it look like there's lots and
lots and lots of people that's a
military tactic where you'll you'll make
it seem like there's more of you
surrounding the enemy to confuse them
set off explosives over there and noise
over there yeah yeah i think these
people feel like they're insurgents
they are insurgents they know they're
insurgents the ones who are not just
like your average like dopey foot
soldier woki
they know what they're doing they're
very informed
they know that they're just trying to
claim power they know what the tactics
are they have books like good or like
beautiful trouble that are active as
handbooks that tell them how to do this
i'm in a bit of a loss maybe you can
help now
i'm a big advocate of turning the other
cheek i i believe if someone wrongs you
you the best thing you can do is just
allow it understand see their humanity
but i also see they crucified jesus
after he told people to do that so like
one time a friend of mine would smack my
leg a lot and i was like ah it really
hurt and i was like stop please stop
hitting me but she she just was doing it
was just programmed to do it and one day
i said if you do it again i'm gonna hit
you as hard as you're hitting me so she
did it again and i hit her smacked her
super hard and she was screamed out and
never hit me again no the situation was
solved yeah you hear this with parents
and children who bite a lot is that they
finally just you know bite the the kid
back and it's like that's what it feels
like they can't ever bite the kid never
bites again
and it's like um there is a point there
uh
and this is where i was saying earlier
you know cancel that if someone comes to
cancel you cancel them first it's kind
of like a it's semi-humorous you know
thing but
um i don't think until i keep saying the
symmetry the asymmetry is the story the
asymmetry is the goal the goal of
repressive tolerance from 1965 was to
create this asymmetry
left good right bad uh marcus in that
essay by the way if you want to see how
touch how close to what's happening now
it is he says that the problem isn't
even that right-wing movements exist and
do things and whether they would be
violent they have to be stopped at the
point where the thought enters their
head therefore it requires not even just
censorship but pre-censorship of
movements from the right
and that asymmetry is what's being
attempted that's what cancer culture is
meant to do cancer culture is meant to
create pre-censorship in other words the
idea is not even out there anymore
people are afraid even if they hold the
idea to say it because if they say
they're going to get canceled they're
going to get shot down off of their
platform they're going to lose whatever
it is that's their living or whatever
happens to be the kids are going to get
harassed at school so pre-censorship to
prevent people from even feeling like
they can say the thing is really their
objective until the symmetry is restored
it's just going to be l after l after l
after l stacking up until people grow
spines
and just say shut up i don't care well i
mean historically speaking from what
i've been told but i'm not a scholar of
this i can't talk about it deeply is is
until the children of the actual elites
start having an impact
the parents i should say of the children
have see it impacting their children's
lives but they're they're it's already
happening
they're playing into it sort of i mean
that's the problem is a lot of people at
that level
have bought into the ideology yeah i
hear from parents all the time that say
like the one thing i wish more
desperately than any is that i could
talk to other parents in my kid's school
and say don't you just think this is all
bogus
don't you think it's a terrible idea
that they're bringing in trans strippers
to dance those people need to have
someone
throw a large ice cold water balloon in
their face well they said what's
happening is they know that if
especially and this is true in private
schools elite private schools that if
they say that to the wrong parent their
kid's going to get pushed out good why
is your kid in that school in the first
place that's kind of that's kind of the
feeling that i have i've been kind of
pissed off at people for a long time
which it's like you know people are like
i'm scared i'm going to lose my job it's
like everybody's going to lose their job
if this goes badly why do you want to
work for a company that's funding this
yeah you know look
the i i've stopped caring a lot about
these autonomous zones to a certain
degree in that portland voted for the
writers they literally voted for the
rioters and a lot of people are like
dude i can't leave i'm stuck i
sympathize i empathize if you're stuck
and you can't afford to leave i
understand but maybe at a certain point
to realize that we live in trying times
and the world is not perfect
see for me maybe it's easier i don't
have i don't i don't have children
i've been homeless before i'm not scared
of it if i had to just walk into the
woods i'd be okay
but too many people are scared they
lived in comfort for too long and
they're scared of losing that luxury
because they don't understand what it's
like to actually have to survive on the
streets and you know what surviving on
the streets infinitely easier than
surviving in the woods and you don't
even have to do that no one's talking
about you know making you a homeless
person living under a bridge we're just
saying they might take your kid out of
the school and then you got to figure
out something for your kid yeah
homeschool them that this is this is the
the truth is that the thing that you
said that we live in trying times now
and people have to start living as
though i mean this is something i get
mad about it the the very smart people a
lot is you know my opinion is i would
agree with you if the world was the same
way it was five years ago i think even
said that i got asked a question i gave
a talk recently at a major university a
very famous major university and um
i got asked a question that was very
much to that you know they were like
well don't you think you turn people off
by some of the way that you behave on
twitter and the way that you behave and
i was like
um first of all i don't care at all good
bye but second of all
most importantly is like i can't first
why buy because i can't put a chain
around my neck and constrain the way
that i need to feel like i need to talk
to say what i need to say because it
might upset somebody who follows me on
twitter i don't care
but secondly
and much more importantly if the world
was the way it was five years ago i
would
or the way we thought it was five years
ago i probably would believe we believe
you or agree with you but it's not
we're in a bad situation right now and
if you don't act like we're in a bad
situation right now and start living
like what time it actually is
then this just keeps getting worse and
it gets harder i told people this at the
beginning of the riots last summer this
won't blow over the longer you wait to
stand up the harder it gets i'll put it
this way you're on it we're all on a
boat and that boat is taking on water
and you've got people like me and james
lindsey and ian and other people we have
on the show who are looking you in the
face right now and say start bailing and
they're going
but you know
i don't i don't know if i should because
like i mean you know that people are
gonna get they're gonna find out that i
know the ship is sinking and then i'd
rather look if i climb to the top of the
titanic and go to the back it's not
sinking over that's actually going up i
think that'll be fine it's like bro the
whole thing's going to split in half
it's going to go under and i'll tell you
this we're all making our ways toward
the
lifeboats we tried baling water maybe
we're past that point now we're at the
point where those of us who've been
paying attention and many of you who are
watching have already started getting
ready for whatever those life boats
figuratively are and a lot of people who
think they can sit back and shut up and
keep their head down are going to be in
for a very very rude awakening i will
tell you once there's a meme where death
goes knocking on every door and every
door has there's like a trail of blood
coming out and the meme will show like
video game companies or movies or
whatever and then he's knocking on the
next door people seem to think i will
sit in my house and as these psychopaths
go door-to-door threatening people if i
put up the flag they'll walk past me and
then oh no one day they don't
they knock on your door and they say
well you're gonna give us money now like
they did to the businesses in in
louisville you know that story yeah they
went the black lives matter went around
to all the local businesses downtown and
said tithe or else and when one cuban
immigrant said no they shattered a pot
and said tithe or else and then they set
up barricades and called him racist and
shut down his business
that's what happens
tithe or else
they demanded a percentage of the income
from these businesses sit back at your
own peril fine but don't come crawling
to me when you keep saying but i'm
scared to talk to the other parents okay
well then you reap what you've sown you
are the one watering the flowers of
destruction and then you're gonna come
and complain about it later dude the
rest of us are getting into the weeds
and pulling out the trash and getting
rid of the grubs while you're sitting
back saying i don't want to get my hands
dirty okay i'll say yes bail
pick up a pail and bale the water love
it also
get the lifeboats ready but i think we
can salvage the hull so if you're
interested in the structure of the
system and you want to repair it that is
also possible but we need to get the
lifeboats ready and we need to bail that
is by speaking your mind online you make
a video
you let people know it's by talking to
other parents yeah and saying that's
ridiculous
no i'm sorry that makes no sense and
then if they get mad and they huff and
puff be like
you met you keep you're cool and you be
polite and you be nice and you let them
freak out
you want them to show their true colors
when they have the tribalist panic
attack that's right and this is why i
always try to be very nice on on twitter
because i want people to look at the
interactions between these lunatics and
see someone saying i'm sorry i didn't
mean to upset you and them saying f you
use slimeball i hate your guts and then
when a regular person is uninitiated
sees that they go i don't want to hang
out with the mean person yeah yeah
yeah um
you can't let the lie come through you
the i said earlier the the soviet union
lasted 70 years of pretty crap
um to put it mildly
do you know what led the soviet union
when it started to actually collapse i
mean there's lots of economic factors
and some other stuff and whatever but
it's when the people the citizens
actually started to laugh
at it it's like everybody knew for a
long time it was a lie and they just
kind of did it at some point they
started to laugh at it and so when when
tim said you know it's one parent
talking to another and saying
that's ridiculous
like i mean it's stupid i guess but
think about harry potter right so you
had your literature reference i can have
my dorky literature reference harry
potter come on harry potter three with
the would the werewolf come on good one
and what which one does he teach right
you have this the boggarts yeah the
shape-changing boggarts the thing that
you're afraid of it is what it turns
into the thing you are the most afraid
of it's going to take away
the thing you're most worried about it's
a shape-shifting thing you don't know
what it is and what is the magic spell
that breaks it that destroys it
ridiculous you call the thing ridiculous
you just laugh at it and that this is
actually a very useful parable because
the truth is this ideology as horrible
and dangerous as it is is also
ridiculous it is patently ridiculous the
things that it says the things that it
claims are
laughably dumb
like you know what you do it's really
really simple get your friends if you're
a parent and you're anti-woke
and then invite an unsuspecting woke
person to your to a barbecue and then
when they're sitting there start
chanting gooble gobble one of us google
gobble one of us and that will
absolutely convince them to change their
minds
or run away screaming you know like in
the movie dude you could do a drum
circle too yeah
yeah it's more subliminal
well it's gotta you gotta be careful not
to appropriate anything then oh yeah
yeah that's snare drums all right let's
let's go to super chats my friends if
you haven't already smash the like
button and subscribe hit the
notification bell if you're listening on
itunes or spotify give us a good review
because
well if you think we deserve it it
really does help
let's see we got here deserves it by the
way we deserve all of the five stars
yeah five stars and thumbs up why aren't
you all liking the like button smashing
tapping like all of the above liking all
of the like buttons i won't say banging
banging yeah
bang that like button
acne products
people are saying
people are saying like the like button
or bang the like button right there
there you go all right acme says it's
been incredible reading your new
discourse's essays and then seeing the
same ideas months later in articles
written by serious journalists dare to
name any names you're always on the
cutting edge of this ideology aren't i
a couple what are some of the essays
that have sparked well i mean
you know i might have did a four-part
podcast series explaining herbert
marcus's repressive tolerance and matt
tybee might have written an article
right after that
that's cool though right on yeah i'm
great no i'm not actually jelly because
i want the ideas to get out there that's
the goal right and i understand the
country club mentality and that's fine
the goal is to get the ideas out there
um i see that claire lemon of quillette
fame is now talking about critical
theory where for like a year she told me
it was too obscure um
it's normal man you know it was a really
weird moment for me when i started
seeing some of my ideas be repeated no
but by other people i mean imitation is
the sincerest form of flattery right uh
there was just a great article i mean
it's truly great but i'll say this i
don't think it's imitation i think it's
a good idea and then people who hear
that and say it's a good idea come to
believe that idea and come to share it
in the same way you did that's correct
yeah there's another great article and i
i don't even remember for sure who it's
by bhatia uh anger sargon or something
sargon hunger i don't remember exactly
what her name is
i'm not familiar with her she's new to
me um
hyphenated last name which makes things
complicated for me
uh if one of you find it that's cool but
she wrote a beautiful article i i even
it's really funny because i predicted on
twitter the day before it came out that
somebody would probably be writing an
article about hegel which i kept getting
made fun of on twitter about that the
hegelian
the philosophy has relevance to what's
going on and she writes this beautiful
article about the hegelian elements of
the woke movement and i was like oh damn
i like literally tweeted about that
yesterday um there you go it's like
you're developing the um
theory or the scholarly presentation and
then other people are making it more
like mainstream palatable i mean that's
part of it i do understand that i write
dork
stuff that's hard to read well i need to
figure out if more people are talking
about the psychopathy aspect i actually
think the most important article i've
written in a long time i published it on
christmas in case because covet because
like we didn't have a christmas this
year because um my mom had a covet scare
at work my brother is absolutely not
hanging out like he's totally coveted
out and then my um
my kids are like scattered to the winds
for the moment and covet makes
everything weird and so then we have uh
i had just gone on a trip and so it was
like eh let's just i'll do christmas at
home this year so i was like well there
are a lot of people are doing christmas
at home alone so i'll put an article out
that i was going to save till a little
bit after and it's called something like
psychopathy and the origins of
totalitarianism and it's super important
to understand that a lot of the origins
of what's going on here are people who
are failing to cope with the world as it
is and create what i called in there
borrowing from
what's his name um
it's terrible to freak a guy's name
right in the middle of something
important but uh joseph piper
pseudo-realities they create false
realities and then they push those
through with a false morality and a
force a full false logical form called
parology and a paramorality and i lay
out this whole article that basically
they're coping with the inability to
cope with the world by trying to force
everybody else to live in their
delusions there you go and uh i haven't
seen the psychopathy article or argument
making it out far yet i really want to
though let's uh we'll we'll read some
more of these widgets the crazy one says
hey tim look up the dates the u.s
declared war on the confederate states
huh someone want to yeah i can either
real quick yeah all right let's see ian
hall says isn't all rap pretty much
anti-woke like even nicki minaj is
alphabet
i don't know what that means what does
that mean don't know
is there any woke wrap is it any good i
mean like
i mean there's no such thing really as
woke art there's it's it's like it's
it's technically kind of anti-art uh
because it's propaganda all right here
we go dr roller gator says hi james hope
you made friends today and that everyone
on the internet was nice is he in all
caps
no oh what what the heck what
caps
deplorable pirate captain gunbeard says
my advice to everyone left of marks quit
being a consumer embrace self-reliance
making and right to repair corporate cop
sellouts will hate and fear a culture
built around that yeah i think so
paul
jamikowski says thank you for being a
light in the dark james keep up the
fight the only thing necessary for the
triumph of evil is for good men to do
nothing yes indeed do not let the lie
come through you soulja nichin
softshell crab says so i have two
questions what can a person from a small
town do to influence politic policies
that help small towns and not big cities
do any of you all play warhammer 40k or
know the lore
i do not i used to i played space wolves
for a while space marines i love
tyranids and no i don't really love them
but i appreciate their psychic ways
they're giant ant creatures that have
enslaved other races but what was the
other question exactly how do you how do
you influence policies that will help
small towns the first thing i thought is
make internet videos because that
affects everyone and give your personal
experience culture that's true that's
right um don't be afraid to actually
write to your representatives especially
if you have like some video stuff that
you put out like send it to them share
them yeah um i also have not played this
game the last game i ever played i
actually lost it's not quite true the
last game ever played but i was playing
world of warcraft in like 2005 or
something oh yeah not like launching
fireballs at something or another
pirates or something and i just realized
i was like i'm putting a lot of effort
into making this
avatar of myself awesome when i could be
putting effort into making myself
awesome oh sounds like you were barely
in the game sounds like dead minds i
mean like level 15 or something mom bro
i was like 57 or something in fighting
pirates big pirates they were like there
was yeah i guess yeah maybe um it's been
a while i forget where maybe like
tanneris or something yeah i don't
remember it was 2005. me too so and it
might not even been pirates i might be
making that part up i might bring like
you know raptors and dinosaurs and i'm
just making strength
yeah it could have been stranglethorn
woody bay level four it was good
yeah yeah 40 something yeah and so
anyways
i i realized i could be making myself
awesome with that time and like 30
minutes later i just kept playing it
just the thought crossed my mind and
like 30 minutes later i was like
i'm done and i've never been able to get
into a video game again i've tried a few
times and just literally can't well just
i had like a three years i feel similar
that happened to me i kind of seeded
back into warcraft 3 in that 2009 but
between 2006 and 9 i just had i took my
warcraft disk smashed it threw it into
the sewer i was like i'm done i have
youtube and i just went deep on youtube
videos i've got i just i just bought
gentian impact it's actually a really
good game but i just can't get into it
because i'm like i'm just not inspired
to level up these abilities you know
it's an open world rpg and i'm like i'd
rather just you know build chicken city
you know what i mean like in real life
real life
yeah i actually like like chickens are
hilarious i started turning the circle
and training my martial art and
meditating in place of video games and
it was like wow i turned off world
warcraft and i have like so many extra
hours a day that i don't even know how
to fill them all
all right we got um mick chewie says
diamond hands my fellow apes amc and gme
to the moon what's up tim and friends
keep up the good work y'all
my friends you may notice that we have
some merchandise pinned to the chat oh
if you go to timcast.com and click shop
or click the pinned merchandise above
the chat you can get your very own
diamond hands gorilla t-shirt it is the
traditional i am a gorilla shirt except
now he's wearing a suit
holding wads of cash smoking he's got
sunglasses on and he's particularly
happy because you see he had diamond
hands he held his stonks until he maxed
out his attendees and now he is reaping
the rewards so he's having a good day
there were a lot of people that were
that's i can't believe it you know the
game stop thing yeah people sold at like
50 bucks oh i'm not giving anyone advice
i'm just giving you my opinion on what
happened and then it hit like 350. yep
then i don't know what happened today
but it's just been insane and i know
some people who bought some and they're
laughing like this doubled their money
like
this this it's a crazy scenario it's
crazy i literally i was on a flight
a few weeks ago and i sat next to a
literal hedge fund manager and it got
upgraded i was in first class and i sat
next to a literal like hedge fund
manager and i was like what do you think
of that gamestop and he's like i didn't
even know about that
i was like what in the world
memes man meme is mightier than the
sword
all right the civic nationalist says
james i used to uh i used the work
you've done to make my arguments against
the racist and sexists you have done
amazing work but they don't care so good
idea is greater than bad ideas god save
the queen long live britain the sun has
not yet sat no we're impeaching the
queen now impeach the queen
that's right people are doing people are
posting a hashtag and peach the queen i
guess
it's like a reference to like
the more the the more absurd stories
come out i can just like
i wonder at what point there will be a
crisis of historical record on me
when they don't know which stories are
real real stories
so like there's a bunch of stories about
me which ones are the real ones i tried
to do that other academic papers
right exactly oh yeah you you talked
about that on rogan you said you you
published like 10 how many papers seven
of them got in there were 20 that we
wrote um turning mineconf into feminist
literature and getting it accepted i
almost you know so tim's like a
journalist or whatever and he was
actually at peterborough's house while
we were writing them
and we had we we had an event a couple
of events in portland and so we got
together in portland and we're working
together and at one point i mean the
famous video when we put out we're all
celebrating and laughing and and what
appears to be a nice house and pete's
wearing like a suit jacket or whatever
like tim's downstairs and we're like
completely fried he was there and we're
celebrating
at one point and i bet you don't
remember this but you might remember
this we were in pete's kitchen
and i had an idea for a paper hit me and
that's like i completely forgot that you
weren't in on it and i just turned
everybody in like it's like the whole
room went weird and i was like oh my god
guys
gentrified cornbread
you were like what and everybody was
like
you know
stop stop
stop well you know i take uh sources
seriously though so i wouldn't just like
publish private details of somebody
unless it was no of course of course
worthy you infiltrated you were well we
were uh we were doing uh uh what we
doing we're doing an interview on
critical race theory stuff yeah i know i
couldn't remember if you were there this
woman james damore was there so i
couldn't remember if you were connected
to that event or yeah i don't think at
the exact same time but we've we stuck
around we drove back and forth i guess
that's right that's right yeah we went
to the james demour thing in portland
yeah and it was portland yeah we hung
out a little bit at pete's house and
then we all argued about
universities versus media and stuff and
turns out we were both right and of
course we were yeah all right let's see
brandon beck says have you seen george
elixopoulos's comic of you tim it's you
feeding your chickens you get abducted
by aliens it's really funny you love the
show i do it's amazing
and uh we've completed chicken city
today
we have two little chicken houses then
two little chicken like bungalows yeah
and then one chicken town hall and we're
gonna put addresses on them yes so then
you know it's like actually we gave
bucko a little tour
let him sniff it out he was stoked he
was running around
like a squirrel autonomous zone in the
middle okay uh oh we'll find out that
sounds great maybe they can get through
the wiring i think no i don't think so i
could hope this girl might be able to
slip we have to be we have to you know
take it seriously though because we you
know we're in the middle of these
predators and stuff no that's true i
mean yeah you're you'll see an uptick in
your foxes and hawks i think it's fine i
think it's fine uh they have little
houses and we surrounded the whole thing
it's it's caged in yeah and i don't
think the squirrels would attack
chickens if not if they did no
yeah the chickens would eat the
squirrels no my neighbor has chickens
they're cool and suddenly they're cool
so uh another question jordan nick says
great uh guys great work love the show
quick question for ian who's your go-to
army for 40k you seem like a tao or
eldar player i love the eldar man but
josh picked him first i mean the
harlequin kiss was so deadly in the
early days if you the distortion cannon
if it hit any tank it would just
completely
the tank would disappear it was so
overpowered so i always wanted to play
eldar but since joshua had my space
wolves i think i like tyranids i like
the psychic worm creature that can
control armies of jean steelers now i
know what it's like for everybody we
will mention magic together yeah you're
going to love 40k tap your swamp all
right this one's important for you brian
clover do you know who that is i do
hey look it's jimmy lindsay he and his
sibling were raised in the old
neighborhood where they were my younger
siblings friends he was just a kid down
the road hopefully we'll be known as a
modern day hero keep going james right
on thanksgiving points thanks brian good
to hear from you man that's cool huh
yeah
all right let's see uh amala shock says
tim you hung the picture now i have to
fix the leaky toilet told my wife i'd do
it when you did thanks
a pisces and nine of spades so yeah we
changed the the image behind uh
james because it was the donald trump
joe rogan one but now that it's just
biden i was like we have two images of
biden eating children you know oh okay
yeah so behind you it's he's eating boom
okay boomer girl not a child but then
behind james we have joe biden just
literally being handed a little girl who
eats biden is all over i don't know what
george alexapolis was thinking when he
made the one of joe biden just eating
the little girl and everyone cheering
and giving thumbs up as he does it but
it is one of the greatest pieces of
modern art i have ever seen have you
seen the meme where they took pictures
of him like creeping on people's hair
and stuff
we'll bring him back yeah memes i love
it
let's see
tim paul says hey tim i always enjoy
your show i just did a metal cover of
will of the people i would be honored if
you would check it out my channel is
just my name
tim paul's it almost sounds like the
exact same name i will look into it
that sounds nice
michael leone says been watching since
fukushima you do great stuff you often
mentioned making culture to impact the
world so minecraft playthrough when
probably never but uh chicken city yeah
did you hear the song that i wrote well
it's people no i'll have to show it to
you later everybody else you can check
it out it's an original song and you'll
love it it's uh uh it's it's very very
very political in fact i think people
who are into politics would probably
like it more than your average music fan
but i think it's a good song i mean i
wrote it i have to be uh proud of myself
i suppose you know what would be cool is
if we had a minecraft uh world of this
house it might be a security
fun breach type thing where we don't
want people knowing the layout of the
house necessarily but if people could
like walk around your house and they'd
be like oh i get to
see what gym sees well what we'll do is
we'll put an ipad on one of those like a
big kind of segway or something and then
you can log in and control it there used
to be they still probably still have
these but there was this thing that um
my brother's friends had where it was a
little robot
that could be remote controlled by
anyone you give access to and so this
guy gave his friends access to drive the
robot around his house and has a camera
on it so you're driving around and you
can yell things at people and it's just
really funny to be this little like
robot in your friend's house like the
dog is like running you're chasing the
dog
yeah it's fun it was fun fun little toy
that's cool all right let's see
woody says lived in sf and worked for a
huge tech company quit after seeing the
critical race theory stuff jl had been
warning about and now thanks to him and
tim castro i finally moved out of crazy
california and never voting dem or lazy
republican again here's to you all right
there you go awesome
oh hello pablo martinez says look at the
post-millennial article of sarah
silverman she's now claiming to be
politically homeless and that's a former
hollywood elite to respect
never been a big fan of sarah
silverman's kind of humor shock humor
where she has like really offensive
things but i love the ability that i
love she has the ability to do it
and so i absolutely welcome sarah
silverman in with open arms to whatever
group we are in terms of not
like politically tribed but still
anti-censorship
believing in truth and weird stuff like
that i i look very weird sarah should be
allowed to say all the stupid crazy
jokes that she wants you know i agree i
got a really good vibe from her 2007 and
just saw like she she could see through
it a little better than a lot of people
she looks like somebody i actually know
in real life so i get kind of confused
there you go all right here you go alan
ortega says thomas sowell was once a
marxist when asked what caused him to
change he simply said replied facts
there you go i mean that's how it works
right it's a pseudo reality yeah
ethos tattoo says i seen someone post
about how much fox makes of of service
providers for their channel off service
service providers what i'd love to see
how much msnbc and cnn make of ad
revenue when a black man is shot by
police it's probably high they probably
get a lot of big boost in ratings you
can actually google search the ad rates
for all of these cable channel all these
shows
brandon toms says james lindsay the woke
jedi the woke jedi excuse me will bring
balance to the force that's the goal
there he goes like watch out you know i
got you you kind of seem like qui-gon
i didn't know if like that was going
somewhere weird um no he's just injured
he said
he adds thanks for harrowing woke hell
for the sake of all mankind i'll show
you all my my pong gin later oh yeah
i showed lydia my pung jin earlier yeah
it's pretty cool it was very thick oh
kevin pilgrim says this guy is freaking
awesome also i wish sour patch lid
saying yes played every time i
accomplished something well there you go
it's an achievement sound
we got a lot of really great uh super
chats from people just giving super chat
so i really appreciate uh
those super chats
i love it eric miller says so the world
is being affected by an intersectional
centipede also tim you should look up
proto-saber oh i know i know about the
proto-saber and uh there was one guy was
it the hacksmith is that his name he
made a protosaber so do you know about
proto-sabers and star wars don't know it
was like they wore backpacks
because like they didn't have the power
source for like the
for like the little like the handheld
yeah exactly and so what this dude did
was he made a gas powered plasma
it's like it's crazy it's
it looks like a lightsaber whoa but it's
just like a plasma jet so it cuts
through stuff is that the thing that you
saw as an ad on in your instagram no it
was a that one's just a little torch
it's a little torch lighter but it's got
like a good beam it's like you can melt
metal that's
cool all right let's see
david hogan says biggest super chat yet
broke warehouse worker from the chicago
burbs been watching you guys for two
years you're the best love you guys
thoughts on the change to propaganda
laws snuck into the ndaa back in the
obama and obama's era
i think that was more about foreign
propaganda i'm not entirely sure i have
to reread it yeah i don't know the law
i think it was something about
stuff that was made for american
propaganda adults overseas could now be
allowed to be played here in the us hmm
yeah i'm not entirely sure that's been a
while i mean we're definitely inundated
in propaganda and there's some books
about propaganda that you should
definitely read um you should also read
edward bernay's
manufacturing consent which is an
important essay it's like eight pages
long he's the father of modern
propaganda right that's correct i mean
we're supposed to say public relations
but that's a piece of propaganda in and
of itself whoa it's meta yeah
infohol says richard dawkins developed
the concept of a meme out of his
contempt for christianity but the idea
of a meme as a virus that spreads
rapidly between minds is oddly useful
for leftism
there you go
yeah memes i mean the the evolution of
of conceptual or symbolic conceptual
things it totally makes sense and and
what happens with what we call memes
like taking joe biden being a creeper
and sticking popular pew's face on it
that's really fixes like that's genetic
material mimetic material combining with
one another d mills says haven't watched
the show yet but just wanted to say
lindsay is an absolute boss i've shared
the new discourses podcast on antonio
gramsci with everyone i know so good
a lot of people like that one you should
check it out yeah i laid out graham she
we talked about gramsci laid out gramsci
and where he came from what he was
thinking what his plan was and how it's
relevant to today it's on new discourses
you can check it out
all right
corey steinfield says i really love the
show and i appreciate the center center
left viewpoint you guys are awesome i'm
getting into crypto and i was wondering
what your methods of buying and storing
crypto were keep up the great work
um
i don't think it's probably appropriate
to talk about the ways in which we well
oh like what websites
there's multiple ones you can use you
can use coinbase blockfy.com is another
interesting one you can use you're not
storing your your crypto if you do that
well someone's storing it it's on the
blockchain you're just using that to get
to it basically if you go to any one of
these crypto distributors or whatever
and you buy bitcoin on their website and
just have an account with them
they have the bitcoin okay you just
agreed that they owe it to you so if
something bad happens like what happened
with mountain gox back in the day you
have no bitcoin yeah it's it's it's
risky but super convenient to move it
around if you leave it on if you're for
the layman you know if you're not it's
cold storage if you have more huge get a
cold storage thing like the nano x i i
have one of those and then you can store
it locally
it's still on a blockchain but you get
to it through local keys what you need
to do is really just make memes memes
like you put a laser on your crotch and
make that your twitter profile
you tweet hotel a lot um you know you
tell everybody that james lindsay's
going to the moon i'll take tim pool
with me i think it's the other way
around but we're going to the moon later
tonight
i forgot about it everybody buy
conceptual coin it doesn't exist but buy
it anyway we can make it very very
easily man spreading it is extremely
easy to make an erc20 token
all right
ted 2 says the military is implementing
a mandatory extremism in the ranks stand
down per secretary of defense to address
extremism in the wake of january 6. we
are being required to watch a two plus
hour speech about white supremacy and
its influence look into it on tim cast
please that's i think i did talk about
it back when it happened before wonder
if that's a new thing yeah no there's a
lot going on the military has been
wokifying pretty steadily for a while i
hear from people at a lot of levels you
know from officer to brass to
to um
enlisted
and it's like people are they're
wokifying the damn thing it's not good
it is not good so if that's you you know
you've got to know the facts for
yourself and don't lose your head when
you're getting you're not going to like
reject this you're not going to reject
the structure of the military if you're
in it so you have to keep your head
what's with all the 40k warhammer 40 000
yeah i love that
well let me let me read this people love
games as i was about to say yeah
so 20-something drifter says tim we need
a clown block we need a death core of
krieg block worse comes to worse we
expose the normies to 40k the emperor
wills it and you shall obey
honestly i bet there's a lot of metaphor
between the the there's the empire the
imperials and the psychic emperor who's
basically they have him like in a in a
his body is like wasted away after
thousands of years but his psychic
energy persists
um then there's space marines are like
genetically altered humans i could go on
and on i don't know too much about it
though taps your swamp
yeah you always just tap the swamp there
you go flap your swamp uh and then cast
dark ritual to get three black mana and
then you know
potence and fire actually indicator and
get your turn one five five and then one
seven seven flying trampoline
turn one five five
seven seven flying trampolines the only
thing i remember from magic
yeah biggest baddest card in the early
days yeah like way back all right
uh siri uh uh siren uh mcgowan probably
pronouncing it wrong
says i'm a 37 year old skateboarder we
look at life from a different
perspective than the rest of the world
we need little my wife and i pulled our
young kids out of school march 2020
we've seen this coming
yes and uh if you would like to watch me
skateboard you can search on youtube for
tim pool nollie hardflip rewind and
hang 10 hardflip and my good friend
brett novak filmed and produced those
videos and they are like some of the
best tricks ever on flat ground trust me
if you want to see me skateboard you can
download the same video and get one of
those uh deep fake apps and put my face
on tim
that's all i got all right let's see
aurora diaz says any thoughts on unrich
unrestricted warfare written by ccp
members that calls for the weaponization
of everything to destroy the west is
there a chance this is just a new kind
of warfare utilizing useful idiots in
another country to destroy it from
within it's an old kind of warfare using
new tools it's political warfare it's
not new we just forgot what it is in the
in the west like i said the communists
assessed this you know 40 years ago and
said that literally the americans
ability to detect political warfare is
so degraded as it may as well not exist
so it's an old fam form of warfare it's
the political warfare it is the most
important concept you've never heard of
yeah it is what is what we're in the
middle of right now all right superman
if he wasn't scared of green rocks asks
tim quick question not looking for
financial advice but how many people on
the show are invested in amc or gme just
out of curiosity well i can say for
myself i have no amc or gamestop stunks
i do not
you guys i don't know nope sorry we're
just not diamond hands enough i'm so
deep in crypto i think that was an
important event though i didn't want to
buy those because as like covering the
story i didn't want to be a contributor
to any like riser gains and then have a
stake in it but i do have nokia because
i actually like nokia i used to do a lot
of tech work with and i have i would
have like every single cell phone and we
did some mobile apps and i was doing
mobile live streaming so when i heard
there was a report that came out that
nokia was doing well it is one of the
meme stocks but i guess it's not doing
well like nobody really cared i just
like the idea of you know having some
stock in a tech company and then like
reports are saying that nokia's gonna do
well so i own some but i'm not giving
anyone advice that was just my opinion
on why i did
yeah i don't have any advice at all
except that i think that it's like you
it's like you know i comment on this i
think the gamestop thing was super super
actually symbolically important yeah
sunny james says they probably can't
fund the police in those areas anyway
half of the cost
i would charge to risk my my life for
those coward politicians cdc issued
warning about zombie virus when all of
them peeps pour out of those starved
cities me thinks
did you guys hear about the zombie the
cdc zombie virus that's like a joke
thing they've always had it's yeah but i
was thinking today we're talking about
earlier without me and adam were on his
show about how hitler framed the jewish
population as rats and if we if we get
to a situation where people are so
homeless and destitute that they start
to roam the streets in desperation and
start eating other humans dead bodies
like cannibalizing that
it may be framed that they're zombies
it's okay kill them all and that people
are desensitized to it because of
propaganda like that dude this is like
some of the best left-wing crowd that i
still have like nobody believes me it's
like i used to see like i never really
watched tv but my friends were all into
like the walking dead and i was like
this is a bad metaphor this is a bad
every right winger is into like
killing zombies big time like and seeing
him everywhere this is not good
uh so it was like i thought i was a
little afraid that the walking dead was
like propaganda for right-wingers to
start thinking of leftists and zombies
and there's like no dehumanization is
good yes like don't do it i agree all
right we'll do a couple more super chats
we got one from jason hopper he says
diamond hands gorilla in pillow form and
haram i'll buy both all right we will uh
i will get those graphics transferred
over to pillows and make them available
for everybody it is our gorilla
yes so that's very that's the mock-up
our pillow yeah the graphic but then you
see the burlap sack over there yeah
that's the official prototype that's the
real one yeah we're doing a commercial
we're
like we're legit going to buy air time
on tv and oh no kidding it depends if we
can get it timed properly so we're
working on it we are and we want to do
it
at a specific strategic political moment
let's leave it at that i told him i've
already talked to fox about it i told
him on twitter that if he doesn't make
one the size of those like bean bags
like bodies like huge bean bags that you
can use as a bed and call it the
hogzilla that it's not real
like he's not committed until that
happens
all right hear him luminescence says hi
tim good podcast any news when laui and
serpenza will appear here
they are concerned about covet that's
their main hold up right now but we are
going to make it happen but but but
everything's reopened
not everything
yeah i'll follow up with them okay
is really good though yeah that'd be
cool he's really good
all right let's see i think maybe we can
grab one more
elle says great show james you are brave
and please know you are in my family's
nightly prayers how do you see this
critical race theory thing ending i've
seen you mention bullets scary stuff um
i don't have i mean like
it matters
a lot and if i'm black-pilled at the
moment you ask me that question
uh
if people will actually do like we've
just said on the show repeatedly which
is start saying it's ridiculous start
speaking plainly and truthfully about it
start showing up and and using what's
left of of the institutional mechanisms
because a lot of the institutions are
not dead a lot of the institutions are
filled with people and i know because i
just spoke with some in the last two
days that just don't know what it is
i have no idea i'm talking about like
legislative bodies i'm talking about
school boards they have no idea that
this is what's actually happening if you
start informing these people this is
like the hail mary
then there's a way out of this where in
fact
it all can almost evaporate as i think
helen put in cynical theories as like a
puff of its own contradictions or
something like that
but if it continues to take over more
and more and more institutions the
the
ways out are very slim
and i don't think that and i don't
advocate
bullets it's a terrible thing i don't
advocate so that is the worst thing ever
but when i say that what i what i'm
actually thinking is that the united
states is not a country that is likely
to go the route of peasant societies
like china was in the 60s or like russia
was in 1917 they're not likely to just
kind of go along with this and fall into
it or germany was in the 1930s
it's likely that there will be fighting
back and that's a worst case scenario
short of just outright losing in my
opinion so start speaking up and
speaking honestly and the way out of
this works out by just speaking the
truth and pointing out this is not what
it purports to be it is reinventing
racism
nobody wants this and start telling
other people that in plain easy language
and you can actually convert people into
understanding this and then
it's like we're not beholden to just
like sleepwalk off a cliff here
uh yeah
this is so important right now all right
everybody thank you all so much for
hanging out smash the like button
because it really does help and if
you're listening on itunes spotify or
other podcast platforms leave us a good
review give us all those stars because
it helps it really does and if you
really love the show you're a big fan
you got to share it
that's really the only way these shows
grow
you know i guess marketing campaigns
don't really work
you got to just have good word of mouth
so we appreciate it you can follow me on
all social media platforms at tim cast
if you follow me on twitter you'll
probably be confused half the time
because it's meant to be a chaotic
garbled nonsense mess for fun and uh i
wonder how long until no one takes
anything i post on twitter seriously
which is kind of the point
but uh my other youtube channels are
youtube.com timcast
youtube.comtimcastnews this show
is live monday through friday at 8pm so
we'll be back on monday but
i mean at this time
we are going to have a special exclusive
episode it's not going to be a podcast
it's going to be the chicken city
okay okay now the chicken city is built
but it's an issue of whether or not we
can actually get the chickens because a
lot of places are saying it's not quite
chicken time yet
but if you want younger chickens you can
have them and i think maybe we'll just
get some you know we'll figure it out i
want to make sure we do it properly for
the sake of the chickens and their
well-being and uh i want to be able to
film it when we do so we might i'm i'm
i'm hoping
that we'll be able to actually procure
some chickens tomorrow and film the
process and show you our little chicken
village it's not very big and that will
be bonus content available at
so we're really hoping with temps.com to
do more than just podcast shows so if
you're a member there will eventually
start being more stuff there will be you
know training videos on the range maybe
luke can do some some you know drills or
he can talk about airsoft and other
things like that and we can just have
some experts talk about some fun stuff
but that's all available over there so
greatly appreciated when you sign up
james you want to shout out anything i
mean you can follow me on pretty much
all social media at conceptual james or
you can follow my my uh outlet new
discourses at new discourses it's on
most if not all of the platforms youtube
channel has all the podcasts it's also
on the other podcasting stuff you want
to check that out it's the main thing
i'm kind of doing if you subscribe
even at like low levels if you subscribe
at all to any of the subscriber things
that i have through new discourses then
you have access to a second podcast i do
for subscribers only that are called
james lindsay only subs i usually don't
script those i just try to talk like
man to mike amanda you and connect so uh
different shorter form more personal
content so i'm going to try to in fact
get into some advice giving and personal
content that on there too so go sign up
at new discourses on any of the
platforms that you like and get into
that cool you guys can also follow me at
ian crossland.net if you want to check
out my social stuff james really cool
meet you man good job yeah okay um i was
on adam's adam kriegler's show earlier
adam cass so if you want to go to
youtube.com atomcast irl and check out
that episode i would highly recommend
and uh thanks for having me everybody
very cool
and i am sour patch lids on twitter and
vines and i am real sour patch lids on
gab and instagram if you guys want to
follow me there i'm so excited for the
chickens i cannot wait hopefully we get
little ones that are still fluffy
fingers crossed because we keep saying
we're gonna have some weekend content
we're gonna have some weekend content
we're gonna go to the range and then
some you know something just falls
through
but i think tomorrow we're going to film
getting these chickens and then we'll
have a special
chicken city episode at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
see y'all then i suppose
bye guys
you